[Music]
hey it's the Halloween show
yeah it's Halloween but I'm so excited
but not for us it's just Friday yeah but
it's almost Halloween it's not Halloween
for you either cuz this is Tuesday you
gotta just like say well I'm gonna save
this show for Halloween and watch it
then or you can watch it now and just go
and then watch it again that's a very
good idea yeah dude you want dawn you
honestly I think the whole month of
October should it's all Halloween just
it should be a month on holiday I think
it's clearly the best holiday ever
yeah Halloween is Halloween yeah I mean
Christmas is cool two Thanksgivings cool
too cuz you get to like eat as much as
you want no one judges for me Halloween
seems like it feels like about like a
week it should be yeah it's like a week
long it should be like Hanukkah but yeah
okay you know what I mean right like
Halloween Hanukkah should be eight days
long yeah I think it should be a whole
month long but you know what I mean okay
so what we're doing for the Halloween
special we don't even have [ __ ] no
weirder well now we got a show planned
and it's gonna sorta take us a couple
days to make this because we're not
gonna do it all at once we're gonna do
it tomorrow night too yeah we're gonna
do this like in bits and pieces so if
you see like costume changes well not
costume cuz I'm just being me just like
right now we're gonna see us wearing
different clothes probably well I'd say
I specifically wanted to wear this shirt
because I made it and like I'm you know
I just not yet I wanted to see how it
came out good that's all yeah okay tell
me what it is this is yeah this is
mantle brothers fertility clinic if you
can't see it might be too small I'm not
sure if he gets all bleed late it's like
really close into the camera then
[ __ ] titties what a douche from dead
brain dead ringers if you guys are David
Cronenberg fans which is actually
probably my favorite Cronenberg movie I
know that's kind of blasphemous in a
world where video drama exists but at
the bottom here it says specializing in
mutant women yeah which you guys have
seen this shoot you get that you're
right
but yeah I'm like I'm making like a
whole series of like horror themed
t-shirts I'm kind of doing them slowly
but this was like the first one I
thought of and I was like I'm making
that because I want that [ __ ] yeah so I
made one and I you know put it on sazzle
I ordered it and I said okay well if it
comes out cool then I'll put it up for
sale I'm on this tour on this as well
store speaking of the Zazzle store
somebody in the YouTube comments asked
me they're like oh well can we get like
long sleeved or hoodies or something
like that and I was like oh I'll make
those specifically but then I went to
the Zazzle store and I'm like oh I'm a
dumbass because when you go to Zazzle
and you pick the design that you want or
the t-shirt that you want um you can
actually pick male/female long-sleeved
hoodie anything like that
because when I put the designs like when
I uploaded the designs I said just put
it on anything black okay so anything
it's black or dark-colored if whether
it's long sleeves or female they can
select yeah it's like it's Zazzle
doesn't have like the easiest interface
I have found like either for uploading
things or for buying things but I was
able to determine that all of the
designs I think that I've put up so far
you do have the option to buy them as a
long-sleeve shirt or as a hoodie or as a
mail cut or a female cut or whatever so
I didn't have to do them specific like I
did one specifically and then I was just
kind of like oh I guess I didn't have to
do that because I could have just gone
down to the thing but like I said it's
not super clear that you could do that
yeah so I you know what I mean but so
I'm saying to the person that asked that
in youtube you can't actually go there
and pick the design you want and you can
get it in pretty much whatever thing you
want like I think I just put it on like
all dark clothing it's because you know
what I designed them for a dark clothing
and not for mention the new computer oh
my gosh I have so many thank yous this
week right okay do you have everybody's
name written down okay that now the
first thank you I want to do a locum
Chinese like kind of in order
I want to thank Lindsay for the PayPal
nation thank you very much that it's
much appreciated I think we mentioned
this on our matinee show from a couple
days ago but our friend Tara made a
little Santa hat for Dennis yeah here
right that is so that'll be his holiday
like get up as well as his Halloween
costume he's dressed as Santa I guess
well elf he's dressed as an elf I was
thinking about this because I was like
well that could be his Halloween costume
too because like that guy that we know
that goes to I bar that goes to like
name's John and he dresses for whatever
reason he dresses up as Santa Claus like
every Halloween yeah it's like every
Halloween event he just turns up in his
Santa so yeah just a hat yeah no he's
got he had like the red suit on well it
was kind of like a it was kind of a
Santa suit yeah what's it like yeah I
just remember the dim maybe it was the
top I didn't see his bottom half yes he
was sitting by we saw him at memento
mori you were supposed to come in
costume but he was like dressed up like
Santa Claus I'm like oh that's probably
the only costume Aeons but yeah so I
figured Dennis can be Santa Claus for
Halloween and he can also be Santa Claus
for Christmas so you know yeah but yeah
so our Fronteras made that and I was I
was like [ __ ] cracking up when I
guess he really does it keeps his little
bald head work yeah and also holy crap
humongous humongous thank you to Ben who
sent me a computer yeah he sent me a
computer yeah I got a rave because
remember I liked [ __ ] that I needed a
new one cuz the one that I have I have a
Mac laptop which this is right here that
you're seeing and I have a PC that I do
other various things on it this he was
very old for now and yeah and he sent me
a computer yeah we just have to get some
stuff out of the dinosaur and keep
adding to drop and get yeah it's just
like yeah thanks this is holy crap I
guess like I could cry seriously gonna
be awesome that's awesome yeah came with
a I got a new mouth got a new keyboard
is good because seriously I eat in my
office - so Mikey
and the dinosaur the dinosaur is
actually gonna become a video game
yeah because Tom here likes to play I
like my dune Emperor it's kind of which
is a very old yen and that's the only
thing that plays yeah it doesn't work on
the newer [ __ ] and there's supposed to
be a way to where you can like do cheats
and [ __ ] but I'm gonna take that I'm
gonna break that down get a different
modern era I'm gonna put that in an
arcade cabinet and make one of those are
like a bar top arcade cabinet yeah we're
very quick doing the theme on the key on
on the dam you don't mean that the key
ah I'll make you a cabinet like I'll
make you the cabinet graphics the
graphics yeah yeah yeah there's there's
poor there is a company - sells for like
about 100 something dollars a kid of
just all the wood you need yeah then you
can break that down tea
some of that stuff and a couple of the
CD ROMs and I'll put that in there and
this you can put speakers in the top of
it and it'll just you plug it in and
just play dude yeah and then you know
could probably I don't know if it'll
take red alert I don't care about any
other game but dude for some reason
seriously you guys I have like the audio
from dune yeah just seared into my love
dude brain because he played it doing it
much yeah like when he had his old
laptop I said they're played they would
still play it he would play it for like
hours and hours I could get lost in -
and it's not all that complicated really
just game on it reminded me you know
what game it reminded me of uh if you
guys remember if you guys are old like
we are I remembered this old game called
populace do you remember that game where
it was like a thing where you would you
could pick like whatever terrain you
wanted like it was like forest or it was
desert or it was like you know [ __ ]
volcanic lava or whatever the [ __ ] you
want it and you could like build a whole
like civilization on it yeah you know I
mean for you so it was like a similar
type of thing yeah you're fighting for
you gotta for younger generation
wouldn't know the game is command and
conquer cuz but it's better than command
and conquer there's three or four
command and conquer I like those too but
doom was better yeah yeah there's the
same basic concept yeah they're all
pretty much this you know it's kind of
like you you see things from like a
bird's eye view and then
you're building a city and then you're
fighting against like should they yeah
but there's like an economy you got a
harvest spice you know and then you
gotta me that's what reminds me about it
you got to make alliances and then
there's cutscenes with video and stuff
in there with the heart codons and you
could play as like the demon from the
movie yeah or or ch House Atreides you
know it's just that game came from the
90s but it's still like stands the test
of time that damn dune Emperor I love
that they have not made and it's the
Dino De Laurentiis style dune yeah and
they have not made a dune gaming forever
I guess the property is in limbo well
like I said maybe yeah like you said I'm
not sure what the what the issue is with
the rights and it's like because I heard
that they were making they were making a
series of it yeah like last I heard they
were like at least talking about her it
was like you know in the early stages of
production or something like that
because remember we always talked about
how they should make a [ __ ] series it
well they need they need to make a new
video game it's gotta be something based
like on the old dune games well I'm just
saying that if they do a new series and
they're much more likely that they will
do it like a tie-ins I put the wrong
game I would think um yeah because I
know that that definitely needs to be a
series honest the David Lynch movie was
like cool oh what's his I know the guy
who did blade runner's making a new dude
movie you didn't know that
Oh is he really yeah that's our they've
already Hugh Villeneuve yeah the foreign
guy French guy
yeah the French guy yeah he's doing dune
right now but it's a movie oh I did hear
about that yeah I did it's not that far
away maybe six months to a year from
what I understand I mean you know okay
that actually that might be badass yeah
because I liked all that I've liked all
that dudes other yeah and you can't do
that in one movie it's probably a
trilogy well yes that needs to be a
series or it needs to be like it needs
to be expanded yeah just be like two can
be just like if you try to cram that
into one move he's gonna be go just the
way it went with the Dino De Laurentiis
movie were there and it's gonna go the
way or make him [ __ ] Dark Tower yeah
where they're making proclamations and
[ __ ] instead of giving scenes and a
bunch of voiceovers and stuff even
though I love that movie I
kind of like it too even though it's
weird and it doesn't make a lick of
sense but yeah yeah imperfect as that
movie is or something to it their
costuming yeah there's like the whole
vibe of it even though like I said that
I read the book but it was like when I
was a teenager so I don't really
remember that much about it so like now
whenever I see the movie I'm just like
this is so cool but I have no [ __ ]
idea what's going on and I'm usually
good at that kind of [ __ ] well trying to
try to make dune into a movie yeah see
that's just um I just like is like
trying to take the book of Genesis and
make that whole thing isn't it is
exactly like I can't do that there's too
many damn stories in there it might be
slightly easier because at least dune
was written by a single author whereas
Genesis was written by a whole bunch of
different people and there's like all
kind of contradictory [ __ ] in there but
it's like I get what you're saying
though it's like a similar challenge
Genesis has creation in there it's got
Cain and Abel it's got Noah in there and
it's got Joseph you know I'm talking
about the story Joe series that that's
all in [ __ ] darren aronofsky get on
that so you know if you were to try to
do Genesis the book of Genesis that's
like seven movies yeah that's what that
would be a series I think that would be
a good I would watch that like I said if
someone like Darren Aronofsky ate it
like some weirdo maybe that what there
was like have you seen that movie Noah
oh you need to see that [ __ ]
that's it was badass and like I'm not
one dude it's in two Bible movies you
know they're usually hokey well yeah
that's why you need somebody that's like
a non-believer to make them write this
this is but the thing is it's it sticks
to what yeah it sticks exactly to what
some of like the some of the extra
canonical versions of it I think what
was it Maccabees I think this was some
of that stuff came from Maccabees which
are not in the Old Testament yes some of
it is like apocryphal you know yeah and
you take the story of Noah and you mash
everything that was known about that you
make a movie into it and that's a wild
ass story about
and I really listen from the heavens
that were embedded into the earth yeah
and then you know how cities had risen
risen up to destroy the earth would they
call him they called him Nephilim yeah
the Nephilim were actually kind of more
like technology and cities and that was
destroying the earth and then the God
decided to dam destroy the earth and the
and it shows the waters of the heaven
and the waters of the earth because what
it says it shows the waters of the
heavens opening up and the waters of the
earth to swallow it which is some bat
weird [ __ ] so in other words water came
out of the earth yeah it says it in
Genesis and they show all that like it's
basically it's basically like Mad Max
and Lord of the Rings that if you made a
literal Bible movie that's exactly what
it would last there's some crazy [ __ ] in
there yeah they had technology it wasn't
real high technology but but you know
the Freeman I remember they had some
cannons in there and they had armor and
you know there was you know and I guess
steam power remember how they had some
of the work machines in the cities yeah
that's Orion smoke black smoke coming
out of there like they were like they
were drilling for oil and stuff it was
awesome steampunk Bible yeah kind of
like it's kind of like Lord of the Rings
kind of like of the Lord of the Rings it
did remind me that's that's what those
stories were that's what they were
intended they were mythos well yeah I
mean where do you think the vegetation
came from man it's like you know what I
mean they took all their cues from that
kind of [ __ ] folklore yeah that's what
it is
legendary people and challenge and
legendary ancestors of the the
Israelites yeah yeah one more shattered
I had to have this was just a person
that asked for a shout-out so I was like
okay why not I said but it might it was
a while back but I was like well we
already recorded this at one show so I
said well I'll give you a shout-out on
the Halloween show this is me Remini and
it's like I hope I'm pronouncing that
right because they very thoughtfully
gave me the fronton pronunciation of
their name because
otherwise I would butcher their
pronunciation what is it mere emini I
mean II wonder where is that name from I
don't know Arabic I don't know yeah but
they asked for a shout-out on the show
okay there you go so there you go I just
go to the show now like I said on this
this is gonna be this is our Halloween
special this is mostly for the fans so
you know it's like so it's not gonna be
like not a normal episode not gonna be
like a normal episode it's gonna be very
ramshackle have to admit like I said we
got some cool submissions of like
stories and stuff so I'm gonna read
those at various points I also have like
you know history of Halloween urban
legend [ __ ] like that like I said I even
have some horror movie recommendations
so I might get into that as well
but I really don't have like a super
like big plan about it how would any of
this is gonna go it's just gonna depend
on how much drinking we do like when we
get tired and we have to stop and like
record again tomorrow
it's gonna be the show it's gonna be
very like amorphous gonna be a good chef
so you know it's like I said it's not
gonna be like a regular well I say it's
not the last Halloween show I was end up
singing in it remember you did yeah I
was singing it well didn't we we had
that talked about that talked about
Shana and Erik here didn't for the last
Halloween sharor was that with the one
before I remember I was singing I was
dressed up and I was singing songs about
you know a legendary southerners you
know I don't I don't have much one
memory of that a tall person aiders oh
never I write because we were talking
about um Orion right Orion that's Ryan
right
that was the Rison's the risen spirit of
Elvis that was
do you remember and this was probably
going back at least a year or two we did
a video about the Orion documentary and
the anvil documentary yeah but I think I
only put it on patreon oh I should put
that in the regular stream it's been
like at least a couple of years yeah
that shitty not but yeah it's a special
it was pretty funny I thought it I don't
even think the Orion documentaries of
where the [ __ ] is that was I think we
said on Netflix I don't even think it's
on there anymore yeah you guys don't
know who Orion was it was a guy who
sounded exactly like Elvis mm-hmm and
was he from Mississippi or Alabama
somewhere around I can't remember
exactly is Mississippi he sounds just
like Elvis he didn't really look like a
yeah a little but he did a little bit he
look like he maybe could be related to
Elvis and that was the legend mm-hmm is
that he was somehow kin to Elvis yeah
like he was like a bastard child why
which my parents generation like my
dad's generation in Mississippi kana
there was a big confusion between Elvis
and Jesus yeah whenever I shouldn't see
how that made yeah there was a you know
because they believed that Elvis could
stop it from rain and you have like a
picture of Elvis
uhit picture of Jesus on one side of the
mantle and a picture of Elvis on the
other
did you like they would read Elvis for
specific things that you would not pray
to Jesus for high booty I didn't believe
in any of this no that's what I mean I'm
curious I was when I was a young kid I'm
talk about like 10 11 12 what a go to
Mississippi for the summers all right
from California even even back then it
was kind of like an alien culture and
the Mississippi of today was nothing
like the Mississippi of the seventies
that I remember from that era yeah yeah
it had advanced a lot you know it's
changed a lot internet and cable TV
changed the South a lot yeah I can see
that this was pre cable yeah the only
new things that were local and there
wasn't much local yeah no so I can
understand how he had programs like
Beverly Hillbillies even though they
weren't from Mississippi but you know
where people from California New York
might make fun of the PBA grandmas oh
yeah they might make a lot of people
from areas like Mississippi because
there was such a vast difference yeah it
well and it's just weird and he gave me
talk about all this you know but I would
go into people's houses that were you
know my relatives or friends of
relatives or friends and they would have
things in the house that would mystify
me even at the age of like eleven twelve
I was like what the [ __ ] what is that
but you might have and you know when
you're a young kid you try to make sense
out of the world and yeah good luck with
it and I'm looking up on the mantle and
they'll have a picture of Jesus next to
a picture of Elvis and they look like
the same guy the difference is is that
the Jesus has a beard on it okay so and
there's different clothing but that
Jesus might be in an Elvis style
position and then you had you know they
get a pose in there then you look at the
Elvis and he's in Elvis clothes but he's
in a Jesus like setting where there's
like he's like looking up and there's
like like white raised yeah yeah with
[ __ ] you're so so I was kind of sucked
into the confusion between Elvis and
Jesus sure and you know you talk to kids
of your own age and you know you know
who's that you know that's Elvis and
then they'll tell you they'll tell you
stuff and they're confused between Elvis
and Jesus as if there was a relationship
between the two that's how hardcore
redneck ism was back then yeah I got
that but you know we're talking about
Laurel Mississippi and the in that
surrounding area and Tupelo
about an hour and a half I think from
there but it was a similar setting too
close a little bitty place so in
Mississippi in Mississippi around their
places where Elvis came from Elvis was a
demigod yeah basically well do you know
I'm not sure if you know this or not but
Nick Cave on his 1984 album I believe
the firstborn is dead he actually wrote
a song called Tupelo yeah and it was it
was talking about the same thing that
you were talking about where Elvis it
was making comparisons
between Elvis and Jesus yeah well that
was I mean basically the theme of the
whole album not exactly because of his
mother it's a very bluesy album but it's
like the firstborn is dead was talking
about Elvis's twin brother who died at
birth and but he was making comparisons
yeah
the Jesus wall anthology that he knew
about that [ __ ] even though he's
Australian that time an area of coming
up in Mississippi in the 70s and the 80s
was a very religious time in
Mississippian and Elvis was a part of
the religious pantheon of the south
really I mean it was legend but so was
Jesus yeah that's what I mean so the
same day I mean Elvis's cooler I think
well and then I Ryan showed up which is
that's later yeah after the death of
Elvis
I almost said Jesus stuck in my in my
and you know that there's that genetic
racial pull to think that maybe their
Jesus and Elvis were the same thing but
anyway
Orion was like the second coming of
Elvis yeah well that's kind of exactly
what he was and if you watch that and
that's how a lot of his fans like yeah
him as well if you look at that
documentary Oh what was called Orion the
man who would be the man who would be
king of the man who would be king you
watch that documentary and you could see
how that confusion can in that fantasy
continued on that not only could Jesus
come back but Elvis could come back and
that this is him and that there might be
some kind of a connection between Orion
and Elvis and they just [ __ ] played
that [ __ ] over the over-the-top about
resurrection themes on those albums oh
yeah you know and he brought a mask say
no in time no one actually saw what he
looked like and with the mask on he did
kind of look like up he sounded he said
exactly exactly like Elvis and like not
even like oh I'm doing an Elvis
impression oh he sounded
golly like Elvis yeah it's Kurt it was
creepy and he was an excellent singer Oh
Ryan yeah and they were all original
works and it sounded like something that
Elvis would sing in a way it's like he
he seemed like later on that he got kind
of bummed out because he was kind of
like well he you know he was a really
good singer and he was a really good
songwriter but it's like well because he
sounded so much like Elvis that's pretty
much all he could do was be like an
Elvis like oh I'm the second coming of
Elvis because he couldn't be his own
singer because he sounded exactly like
Elvis yeah and as soon as they took that
mask off of him though that was kind of
pretty much his career started to do it
I was like kiss taking their makeup off
yeah but then they had fans southern
fans of his women mostly so infatuated
with this concept that they were trying
to get his DNA and match it with Elvis
DNA to finally prove that they were
related yeah they weren't related though
no that was like the the documented
spoiler alert but like the documentary
that he was trying to find out like if
he was actually because it weren't any
more related than I'm related to him
yeah I mean it's not crazy to think that
I mean Elvis might have like banged a
fan somewhere it's um you know the past
and she might have got pregnant it's not
a crazy thing to think about yeah but
yeah that part of Mississippi that look
is this is common from that time dude
there's a lot of people that look like
Elvis yeah that those are common
features it's all that same stock
basically so they're all inbred is what
you're saying no it's all that same
stuff well there's there's always been a
question about what race was Elvis Elvis
always kind of came across as that maybe
he was something very exotic his mother
was Jewish but there's some confusion
about that too because a lot of mrs.
Mississippi Christians were Jewish
which this is a weird [ __ ] you know what
the [ __ ] you talking about there were a
lot of Christian cults in Mississippi
some of them believe that you could not
be a Christian with
being a Jew first I can see how that
would happen so what you did was is that
you converted to Judaism and from
Judaism you became a Christian well
because you I mean Jews are like the og
Christian exactly they were there before
the Christians were so there were small
Christian cults that had the Star of
David and the cross okay but it was a
type of Baptist which that throws a
whole nother [ __ ] spin on it because
that has very weird they were yeah I can
see where they're coming from yes a
story the story of Judah of of Elvis's
mother being Jewish is a Mississippi
legend what they're probably talking
about and it was back in the 1800s when
when Christian misses some of the
Mississippi Mississippi Christians were
also Jewish but anything to do the race
it was just religious affiliation so she
probably had nothing to do with in the
other races they were just regular white
people yeah okay and then there's
another thing about being some kind of a
mixture of like black Irish or weird
Irish words you say black Irish it's not
African but it's kind of like a Indian
and Irish or something like that alright
but probably not is it was just a red
roll white guy from Tupelo yeah he stood
out so a lot people thought there must
be something different about him because
he was so [ __ ] famous yeah I mean
yeah yeah it's it's myth-making
yes so there has to be some kind of
different a different ethnic origin to
him but knowing the way Mississippi
people are coming up in that area know
he was just a regular white guy well
like I said it's it's kind of like a
whole thing where when someone gets
famous enough like people start
attributing all kind of like because
this person must be special in some way
you know whatever way that is whether
it's like you know there's some exotic
there from exotic place yeah they're
[ __ ] or there's some like other
amazing thing about them yeah well Elvis
knew that he had pictures
of his mom and little things like little
star of David's associated with his mom
and that side of the family but that's
1800s and back in the 1800s and 11th the
late 1800s there were some Mississippi
Baptist cults that had Judaism symbols
in them that's what they're talking like
I said I can almost like yeah I can
almost see that more than like the
separation between the two religions
because they're very similar it's like I
don't
yeah well in certain fundamentalist
thinking how the hell can you be a
Christian if you're not a Jew that's
what I'm saying
so that I can almost but like I'm not
religious at all but that makes more
size because Christianity is a Jewish
[ __ ] that's what I mean it's an offshoot
so there were preachers running around
in the south that part of their gimmick
is that whatever like we're going back
foundation yeah exactly I'm a real
Christian priest and I have a real
Church which means that you have to be a
Jew right and then from that mental once
you're once you're a Jew then you
convert to Christianity yeah so you can
become a real Christian and then accept
baptism so you could be a Southern
Baptist all right
that's just the thinking it's that's the
thinking but his mother was probably
Southern Baptist old-school Southern
Baptist did have that on which makes a
lot more sense than this tale of see the
whole thing about Orion though is like
didn't I come about because of that
novel about the guy that was like an
Elvis impersonator or the Elvis reborn
or something like that and that was his
name Ryan and that's where they got the
name from I don't know much about it
yeah but I think they talked about that
in the documentary Oh Ryan was like the
last gasp of the of the southern hold
that Elvis would return then he was
still alive but he was still alive of it
no they knew that that wasn't him yeah
they thought that based on the he was
like reincarnate yeah they based on the
icons on the backs of the album's and
the lyrics they thought that maybe
it was the spirit of Elvis head being
channeled through this guy or had
returned from the grave a reincarnation
because the ages didn't quite match up
to I don't think I don't think Orion was
quite old enough to be to be young
enough I guess you could say yeah he
wasn't quite young enough I think he
lived alongside Elvis for a little while
that's what I thought to you so it was a
spiritual thing and it was Elvis died in
what 1977 right yeah and he was alive by
that I think right that's what I'm
saying because he's obviously older than
me and I was born in 1972 so I can
remember the magical thinking of
Mississippi of the 70s in the 80s oh
don't question the [ __ ] okay well yeah
question anything you're dealing with it
you dealing with a you deal with the
spiritual people that's what that's how
they would describe it what is something
bad enough might make make it happen
sure might make it real I get that yeah
I get that
and that's that's the games that that's
the games the southerners played story
though it is though I'll I see you I
like that can you know that he's got
songs on YouTube you can he did dude
he's singing gospel and all kinds of
[ __ ] he did a little bit of rock and
roll but it's mostly gospel and like you
said he did his own he didn't do just
like Elvis covers original originals
yeah but sounds just like him but you
know in a way I felt bad for him but
what was funny is that he sounded that
we sounded like Elvis naturally yeah
that's one thing that's why that's why I
felt bad for him because it wasn't like
oh I'm trying to be an impersonator ya
know people that went to school with him
said that he sang great and he sounded
like that was back then
yeah and he wasn't trying it was just
just a genetic marker probably just from
that area maybe something about that
voice yeah not embrace asipi head up
okay
Mississippi had a big breeding
population for it for the population
density and it also
and black people were involved that's
another thing well I know that yeah
right
I what right yeah I know for sure like I
look a little bit black yeah yeah yeah
mine too right so well like I said there
was a lot more mixture of the racing
people think that people imagine back in
the old days because like like I said
it's like what are you gonna do man it's
like [ __ ] you're out of the frontier
right not a lot of people around not a
lot of women around what are you gonna
say no she's a little bit like she's a
little bit paler than you or she's a
little bit like more coffee colored than
you
segregation happened to after slavery
that's actually very moderate in a way
segregation was modern
there were stuff going on there there
was stuff going on in the 1700s 16 17
and 1800s it was going on it that people
you know they were there people were
marrying each other yeah yeah black
people white people were marrying each
other back then it's just that it's a
forgotten about yeah I feel like it was
like okay for a while and then suddenly
everybody got like their panties in a
bunch yeah it was later that was much
later um which is weird to me yeah but
yeah that's seriously that's what
happened
specially in a New Orleans area yeah
which is close to Mississippi so Hannah
yeah it's all about that small of a
piece sure all right so what should we
do first should we talk about Halloween
history should we give horror movie
recommendations what should we do I
don't know like know what order you want
to do this [ __ ] and do what you want oh
that's that's not the answer that I
wanted I said like I said we have read
your stories that I want to do um but I
also have like history of Halloween that
I would like to kind of get into that a
little bit um also I have like a [ __ ]
ton of like horror movie recommendations
just a horror movie recommending about
movies and stuff what I did earlier now
because we have the retrospective show
and because we have the matinee show
which is usually like really new stuff
and then the retrospectives usually
older stuff so I wanted to kind of like
do recommendations that were like
in-between that like maybe movies that
came out like in the last five to ten
years that were on various streaming
services and that maybe people be going
through the streaming services and would
be like oh well I want something good to
watch so I wrote down a whole [ __ ] ton
of one said I wanted to talk about
Klingon talk about like at length or
anything like that I don't want to spoil
them for anybody but I did like write
down a whole big list for shudder for
Netflix and for to be which is free so
if you want to watch any of these don't
yell at me if you didn't like them I
liked them so that's why I'm
recommending if I didn't like them I
didn't recommend them but uh you know so
I just wanted to kind of get into that
now let me get my little net all my
recommendations as you can see ever done
all these recommendations here so we're
gonna talk about a few recommendations
for horror movies pardon me if you need
some horror movies to watch for
Halloween like I said don't yell at me
if you don't like it because I liked
these and I thought they were kick-ass
so let's do do you want to do shudder
first yeah all right let's do shudder
first now no the first one I'm gonna
recommend on shudder they actually only
put this up a couple weeks ago and I've
been wanting to see this for a long time
because a lot of people recommended it
to me
the Taking of Deborah Logan now this is
found footage and I know all of your
eyes are rolling at the moment my eyes
were rolling also I do not like found
footage generally however this one is
kick-ass it's really good it's basically
about um like a team that's making a
documentary about Alzheimer's and
they're living in the house with this
woman who has Alzheimer's and she starts
getting like doing weirder and weirder
[ __ ] and you don't know if it's like
Alzheimer's or if she's like possessed
by a demon or what so it's like it's a
really good there
a reason for them to be filming stuff
it's the main character that's a hit
like the woman that plays Deborah Logan
she's apparently like and she's an older
woman and she was like on some soap
operas like back in the day so she's
like kind of a well-known like soap
opera actress she is like amazing in
this as somebody that has Alzheimer's
disease like she knows she has it but
it's like she has these spells where
it's like she doesn't remember [ __ ] but
so you don't know if it's possession or
Alzheimer's and it's like [ __ ] just gets
weirder and weirder and there's like
just like hints that there's paranoia
all kind of [ __ ] going on and it's not
some but it's not demon possession
exactly like I don't wanna spoil it or
anything and I I will say like one of
the last images in this and if you've
seen it you probably know what I'm
talking about one of the last images of
this that they captured on film of like
her just attacking one of her victims
that's how I'm gonna say it I didn't
want it I was gonna use one word but I
won't use another word because it'll
give it away but it looks really good
this was like a creepy this may be crude
for the [ __ ] out seriously and it's
really good like I said I don't like
found footage so so this is a good one
so that is on shutter they just added a
couple weeks ago also and I think I've
mentioned this one before probably
haven't I the love which I don't think
you mentioned dead I think I mentioned
it on some other show but it was
probably like a throwaway okay this one
this is [ __ ] cool if you like giallo
movies and you really like like old the
aesthetic of like old like 1960s kind of
like the movie it's weird because it's
like it's set in the modern day but the
whole kind of like Gestalt of it is like
all old sixties [ __ ] like everybody's
like wearing sixty stuff and it's like
you know the whole like the design of
the apartments and everything's very 60s
it's just like it's so beautiful to look
at it's not straight up a horror movie
yes it's about a witch and she's like
about she's trying to like find someone
that will
love her so she's like giving people all
these like love potions and stuff and
it's going wrong every single time
mm-hmm
so it's almost kind of like I don't know
it's really but it's it's like a G Allen
movie but not like it's not a murder
mystery it's more like a witch story
like you know old school potions and
stuff like that but just like the
aesthetic of it is amazing like I'm just
sitting there watching it going how the
flike just all the costumes and like all
the [ __ ] sets and everything like
that it's just it looks incredible so if
you're really into like 60s horror or
giallo movies definitely to check that
one out because that is [ __ ] like I
said yeah it is very oh it's so awesome
it's so I think I saw certain clips
certain a certain yes little snippets of
scenes and it and like I said it's set
in the modern day because a couple of
the characters have cell phones and [ __ ]
like that and some of the cars are
modern but it's like you know when you
go inside the girls apartment like when
you see her outfits like her friend's
outfit stuff like that everyone is like
very 60s it's very 60s like the insides
of the clubs and everything like that
but yeah if you're into like the 60s
[ __ ] or like witchcraft or anything like
that it's like super cold um another one
I want to recommend is the whaling this
is a Korean movie and this movie is like
okay this is probably one of the best
ones on shudder but it's very long so
this like a it's a commitment it's like
over two hours if I remember think it's
two hours and 20 minutes or something
like that
now like the first part of it is almost
like a police procedural but almost like
a dark comedy because like the cops are
kind of like bumbling you know what I
mean but then there's also some kind of
like possession [ __ ] going on too so
it's like this one it's like it kind of
good it's it's very like rambling and
it's kind of all over the place but
still it kind of works so if that sounds
appealing then probably you should check
that out but this is like a really
really really good maybe so I have a
huge list so I don't want to like be
here all day like checking the [ __ ] out
okay so another one that I have is last
shift
this one was actually filmed in an
abandoned police station right here in
Sanford Florida where we live this is
it's almost kind of like a bottle movie
like it takes place in one location it's
kind of about a woman and she's like a
rookie cop and she's like given this
task that nobody wants where it's like
she has to like oversee this [ __ ]
abandoned police station like all the
cops have like moved to a newer one that
they just built so she has to stay there
to guard like the [ __ ] that's you know
all the [ __ ] that's still left in like
the storage or whatever so no one takes
it so she has to stay there overnight to
guard it and then all of this like weird
like supernatural [ __ ] starts to happen
like people start to come in and like
they're ghosts and like there's just all
this kind of [ __ ] and then there's like
a cult [ __ ] later on that's like really
good also but I really really likes this
one a lot like I said not Mary not very
many characters and it's like you know
just very one location but very very
good um also the void if you guys
haven't seen that if you're into like
80's horror Lovecraftian horror if
you're into the thing or anything like
that you definitely need to see the void
that has been like kind of recommended
all over the internet in case you guys
haven't seen that another one summer of
84 remember that one being very good
about this one had a little bit yes its
1980 so it had a very stranger things
type of thing going on also had a little
bit of a fright night thing going on
which that because it's his next-door
neighbor he believes is a serial killer
that's like killing people in his
neighborhood so it's kind of like that
it's more like a thriller than a horror
movie I feel like a little bit but it
has comedy to it to God about it but
it's comedies yeah this is the one where
the guy came
they all had mud had a mullet and then
yeah yeah and the handlebar moustache
like them well somebody did yeah one guy
did I remember all that yeah but this
yeah I roll all the time and well no
that was stranger thing stranger things
was it okay I'm getting all confused
probably drunk already
yeah yeah well I'm [ __ ] loaded but
know what happens to a lot of these
movies is that I can't get them straight
and I'll merge two or three of
together yeah because here's how it
what's it's like sometimes like because
seriously I love horror movies and I
would just like if I had nothing else to
do I would just watch horror movies like
all the time and yes so he would get
sick of it after all sometimes who watch
like 1 or 2 at night but you know he
either like he'll watch it if it like
captures the attention or not he'll just
like go on his tablet or whatever and
not really pay attention to it and then
if something [ __ ] up happens he'll
look up and be like yeah I'd be like
listen to the news or something you know
you know whereas I could just like watch
them like all day every day I do not get
bored of them I can't get lost in in I
can't get lost in stories and fantasy
all the time I have too much of it I
don't know I guess it's coming from the
military and you know having PTSD I have
too much of a situational awareness I
want to know what's actually happening
somewhere yeah I can't go off into damn
lala land too long too for too long I
don't well I don't know if it's that but
it's just kind of like because I have
that too it's like the reason I don't do
that is because I have too much other
[ __ ] I have to do like you know what I
mean because I'm you know I I freelance
so I have to work all the time or I
don't eat so you know I have to like
always be aware of like work work work
but if I didn't have to do that if I had
like a billion dollars and I could just
like skate forever I'm like I would
still do creative [ __ ] I would still
design games I would still write novels
I would still do that kind of [ __ ]
because I enjoy that but some days I
have to be honest with you I would
probably just get some booze and just
lay down and just watch horror movies
like all day and it's like I don't get
bored of them because how could you get
bored of them there's so many different
ones the thing with me is that I have a
problem watching any old movie yeah
because it's a story that's coming at me
and it's being told to me by a person or
maybe a group of people and when the
story comes at me the wrong way I go
who's telling this story [ __ ] [ __ ]
tell it what a dad well you know I get
mad you know I'm like he's trying to
scare me with that you know it's that
Coste well I'm am
yeah that character is upset because of
this man I don't want to hear this guy
you know it's very different
okay put yourself in a position where
you're being told a story of bravery and
honor by a person that doesn't know what
bravery or honor is you're not gonna be
able to tolerate it that's the way I see
ya but I don't know it's here's the
thing I'm a very I'm a very laid-back
person in some ways so I mean I'm very
willing to take people as they are and
also take a movie as it is yeah so it's
like if this is what someone made and
they chose to put it on the screen and I
chose to watch it then I'm gonna watch
it and see and I'm gonna give it like
the benefit of the doubt like I'm not
saying that I don't see [ __ ] that I hate
because I do yeah
but generally if I chose to watch the
[ __ ] I will usually watch it to the end
and that's it really really annoyed
Mayer bored me or whatever then I'll
turn it off but I don't usually I will
usually give it it's two hours or no and
a half or whatever and I'll just be like
alright just what do you want to show me
and then I will try to find something
that's what me and Jenny offer our show
offers a well-rounded opinion of things
because we come and we come at a problem
from different around two different
directions I came from a long series of
institutions inside the military
industrial complex where it's just
nothing but just one long series of
[ __ ] process of elimination you gotta
be eliminating the weak link over and
over and all you know I mean it's it's
like a Darwinian process of elimination
yeah
and it's real easy for me to go I know
that's [ __ ] up get rid of that you
know I mean so I'll just eliminate
something quickly so it's hard for me to
get into a movie from washing it and the
tone doesn't match
the material and a character does or
says something that does not fit into
the Gestalt of the story and I you know
I see a problem a major problem
especially if it's early on I reject the
story yeah it's just and I can see that
some people do have that yeah it's just
I guess because because I write novels I
write nonfiction I design games I do all
this kind of stuff so I do a lot of
creative stuff so I'm willing to give
people like I'm just like okay I
understand this is you this is your
vision like show it to me and like I
said I'm I'm usually willing to watch it
all the way to the end even if I'm not
super invested in it because I just want
to see where it goes I want to see what
you do with the difference I mean yes
Jenny Jenny and I when we went to see
see like what was it the last Jedi yeah
so last Jedi we saw the same movie but
Jenny and I saw two different movies she
liked it I just I didn't mind it I was
five minutes into it and I was going
[ __ ] this movie
[ __ ] this book well now here's where I'm
gonna differ with you because I'm pretty
sure you liked it when we saw it but
then afterward no I didn't lie you
didn't like it
no I didn't well it's the first warning
sign that went on is when he dam prank
called the dam empire yeah I remember
that remember that I did and the thing
there is the thing that makes me laugh
is that people get so like I don't get
like if I don't like something I just
forget about it it's like but I I don't
get this thing where people get like
they just go on and on and on about [ __ ]
they don't like it's like I don't I
don't get that I'm a bastard if I if I
don't like something I just forget about
it well I know that Star Wars was
important to me that was what to me too
but it's like okay it's not so important
that I'm just gonna file that's not that
good I'm just gonna forget about this on
the Phantom Menace and I didn't really
like that and I was just like oh well I
didn't like yeah well I didn't like that
one which was phantom Manor it was the
first of the prequels oh yeah and
Phantom Menace I'm not
about Phantom Menace right now no I'm
just saying I was the weakest of the
prequels I'm just saying for an example
I would supervise my Star Wars Revenge
of the Sith I was super into fit you
know I was super in Star Wars I was
really excited to see Phantom Menace and
I saw it in the theater I'm like did I
like that I think I didn't like that and
then like but I didn't get upset about I
was like oh well then you have had long
conversations what was wrong with the
damn Star Wars prequels man it's Phantom
Menace Jar Jar Binks was the problem in
fan of medics well among many other
things and Coquina s-- Luke Ian will
George Lucas in know George Lucas Lucas
Lucas Ian [ __ ] also the character
like what like it was fun it was sand
it's like this has been this has been
kind of like gone over many times now we
know by the time Revenge of the Sith
came around it was a pretty good it was
a pretty good series
so no Darth Maul was the only cool thing
about that yeah there was a no there was
a lot of cool [ __ ] and if that was the
only cool thing but ok I'm getting back
to what I was talking about when I saw a
[ __ ] Leia Poppins or lay a flying
through space I was like oh [ __ ] no no
way
and then and then the kanto bite scene
didn't seem right the tone was totally
and then the whole thing about what's
the fighter pilots named Poe Dameron Poe
Dameron yeah Poe Dameron and the thing
with the the Admiral what's-her-name
with Holden hold oh yeah he you can
remember all these names I can't
remember these these characters don't
mean anything to me but the the whole
that whole thing did not make sense as
an ex-military man the commander doesn't
withhold information about the plan okay
it just didn't that just did not [ __ ]
make sense and then you had a part where
[ __ ] the ex stormtrooper what was the
ex stormtroopers name again
Finn Finn yeah Finn goes to sacrifice
himself to save his friends and then
then the Chinese girl stops him from
from his sacrifice and then says some
[ __ ] there's some crazy [ __ ]
we're gonna win this war by what it's
just by spy by saving those we love
instead of destroying who we hate no
that's not how war works it's just it's
definitely that this you can tell the
difference between this that [ __ ]
story okay we told them you can tell
yours between a person who has never had
any kind of military experience and a
person who does when it comes to writing
a story because the generation of guys
who wrote the originals those are World
War two vets they knew what war was like
so they could tell a Star Wars story
they knew about you know sacrifice and
the honor of service and even the Empire
was portrayed as an honorable adversary
of professionals you know what I mean
because because they were you just they
were just doing what they were ordered
to do you know and yeah they were
supposed to be the Nazi Empire but the
Nazi Empire was doing what it was
ordered to do and you know they didn't
make them look like fools and if they're
fools then that means they're not a
threat
to be a threat you have to be the real
deal you know so that was the problem
with Rian Johnson's take on the Empire
if they're a bunch of idiots then that
means they're no threat it doesn't work
okay you can only be a threat if you you
know know what the [ __ ] you're doing all
right so we're doing more horror movie
recommendations it's like I said this is
a very ramshackle yeah we didn't get far
into that [ __ ] started going down a Star
Wars path that's what before you started
going us okay I'm just saying I don't
understand and I just told you this
before which other microphone I don't
understand people who make entire videos
about [ __ ] they don't like kinds awesome
I don't get that it's just like if you
don't like something then just forget
about it I'm just saying like why why
make like a 20 30 40 minute video what's
whining about show you don't like I
don't get it it's the same thing it's
the same thing about like commenting on
video like somebody
that never watches your videos and then
they comment like on your video like you
guys suck it sounds like what did you
bother just a bother I have high
standards for Star Wars and a lot of
people do you know I mean they expect a
real good movies they expecting good
movies you know and in that particular
movie
I don't think villains are I don't think
villains I don't think the enemy is
scary unless they're shown in as being
competent we'll see the thing is clown
is well I think the thing too is that I
don't expect anything I just I that's
why I don't watch I I mean I watch
trailers like if I can't avoid it but I
don't want to reviews I don't read
reviews or anything like that before I
go see a movie that I want to see
because I don't want anybody's stupid
opinions like cladding like I don't want
any preconceptions about it I just want
to like take it as it is and see how I
feel about it okay you know yeah so I I
just take things as they are not me I
don't have any like preconceptions about
[ __ ] I don't have any like oh I expect
this to be really good like sometimes I
expect things to be good and it's a
disappointing and stuff but it's like I
usually try to like temper my
expectations I try to not expect nothing
I just I just want to see how it is I
expect Star Wars to be at least a Star
Wars like substance you know cheese like
so yeah yeah Star Wars like substance
yeah you know I don't think really dizzy
but like I said that movie came out like
two years ago and that's like the newest
coming out in a couple weeks I know yeah
it's like you know it'll be good to see
it I'm so like I said alright I have no
expectations we're gonna see it but I
think it's gonna be a [ __ ] show and then
see I have no expect so many dark fates
coming out here in a few days and
Brandon said it was said it was okay not
Brandon Oliver
yeah Oliver Oliver Harper held the
Harper sit was okay go watch his channel
and he kicks us it was okay we'll see
we'll see like I said I am he I have no
I expected I'm not gonna get butthurt as
bad he's like I'm not because he said it
was okay I'm a little bit I'm a little
bit more optimistic about it cuz I trust
his opinions on things huh yeah like I
said like I get excited about stuff like
I was excited to see like the light
because I loved the witch the you know
Robert daggers who did the direction and
it's like you know so I was hoping it
would be good obviously but I'm I'm very
much this I'm just gonna like take this
as it comes and like see how I feel
about it I don't want to bring any
preconceptions to it because like I said
I'm a creative person I'm an artist
myself so it's like I know how that [ __ ]
goes so I don't you know I kind of want
it to be like an unbiased I'm trying to
come at [ __ ] from is like an unbiased as
possible you know what I'm saying
right yeah I try to do that I don't
always succeed but I try to do that so
what were you doing so we were doing
like shutter recommendation yeah
all right so summer 84 was the last one
that we were talking about um another
one that I would recommend very highly
is one called terrified I believe this
is Argentinian was an Argentinean or
some herb an Arabian or something like
that I remember that one it was
basically like about a whole haunted
neighborhood it wasn't just like a
haunted house but it was like a whole
neighborhood that was haunted one of the
best like [ __ ] opening scenes
whatever like this woman like in the
[ __ ] bathtub that was like slamming
against the wall and [ __ ] like that it
was like super cold but yeah so check
that one yeah this is a really good one
also and this is actually this is
actually on shudder at the moment and
this is probably one of my favorite
horror movies of the past ten years
easily starry eyes and I have written
extensively about it on my blog which is
called goddess but how fire if you want
to go check it out this is an awesome
awesome movie I just I love it so much
it's basically like it's like a kind of
Rosemary's Baby sort of thing but it's
also kind of like a dark side of
Hollywood type of thing you know it
means kids kind of like sell your soul
like for stardom type [ __ ] I don't
remember
and it's also out of you didn't see I
don't think um and it also has like some
really super grotesque body horror
I mean it's revolting but in a good way
so yeah I would definitely recommend
that very very highly
because that's seriously one of my
favorite movies the last 10 years
another good one that is on shutter is
called downrange now this is one that
shows you don't need a big scope to make
a really good suspense suspenseful
horror movie this takes place entirely
on like one thirty foot stretch of road
right it's like basically these people
are going like on a road trip or
whatever they're you yeah like none of
them know each other it's always like
going down by sniper and they get pinned
down by a sniper okay I saw in this one
like bit of road and it is like a super
compelling super gory it's just really
really good I had a really good time
yeah I always saw bits of it yeah I saw
the end of it because I was doing
something else came in and I saw it it
looked really good it's really good it's
really good yeah yeah it was a man's
kind of movie but like I said it's one
of those ones that shows and like I said
you don't need a huge budget you don't
need like a bunch of locations you don't
need a bunch of special-effects good
right you just need a good writing unity
characters you need so this one is like
really really good I really like this
one a lot um another good one that's on
there is called honey moon this one I'm
not gonna say too much about this one
because I didn't know where this was
going like when I started watching I
just saw somebody like recommend it oh
this is a good one
that was on I think it was on Netflix at
the time so I watched on Netflix at the
time but they were like yeah watch this
one it's really good so I didn't know
where it was going I didn't know what it
was about or anything like that because
like I said I like to approach things
without preconceptions so I watched this
and I didn't know where it was going and
it was [ __ ] great it's oh it's so
good it's just like it's basically about
this couple they just got married there
on our honeymoon they're at this like
remote cabin that like the UM the wife's
parents used to own and then all of a
sudden the wife starts acting like super
weird like she disappears into the woods
one night and it's like then she starts
like doing weird [ __ ] like she has this
notebook where she keeps like writing
down her name and her birth date and
like all this stuff like she has to
remember like she's like forgetting
stuff and it just kind of goes up like I
said that's all I'm gonna say about it
because it's better if you don't know
where
going because I enjoyed it much more not
knowing where I was going because I was
just like what the [ __ ] is going on with
this chick man it's over yeah it was
like super super cool another one I
really liked that's on shutter is called
Sam was here I love these types of like
creepy ambiguous like this is one about
a dude that's like he's in he's on like
a road trip or some [ __ ] like that he
stops at some [ __ ] gas station and
then like you don't know exactly what's
going on through the whole thing you
know what I mean but it's just like you
know it reminded me a little bit of
children of the corn in a slight type of
way but not exactly that's not exactly
where it's going and it doesn't
necessarily tell you exactly where it's
going but I like that kind of show
usually so yeah that's a good one to
last will and testament of Rosalyn Lee
now if you like kind of slow burned
ghost stories this will be right up your
alley
this was actually written and directed I
believe by Rod Gdynia who's the guy
he's like the editor of Remora magazine
which is like the best horror magazine
ever that's based out of Canada and so I
was excited to see this because it's
just like I love that magazine it's like
I've been buying it every month or every
three months I think comes out now and
um so this one was like it's like I said
it's a slow burn so if you don't have
the patience for that then you probably
won't sit through it but I really really
liked it I thought it was like a really
really good kind of creepy like bill
that there's like some really creepy
imagery and it was like whole dread
infused kind of atmosphere and I really
liked that type of thing there's also a
couple of series on there other than
Creepshow which we talked about a lot
there's actually a mini-series on there
called beyond the walls I think it's
French or Belgian it's I think it's
three episodes and that one was really
really good it's basically about this
woman and she like runs a house and
there's like all this it reminded me a
little bit of house of leaves by Mark
Daniel skp you guys have read that where
it's just kind of like you go behind the
walls and then there's like all this
[ __ ] like behind there that
really be behind there you know I mean
and it's like endless and they don't
really explain yeah it seems like that
yeah so it's like it's kind of like has
that kind of surrealistic atmosphere to
it but I really really liked it like I
said I think it's three episodes so
those trees are I'd be in a mall I walk
into one store and when I go into the
store I'm in another store yeah long
store yeah and then everything I do I go
up the escalator to get out and I'm end
up downstairs
yeah no matter and there's no way out of
the damn mall you probably like House of
Leaves yeah yeah maybe well maybe it's a
little bit of a dense novel I have it
somewhere but it's like I had had a
dream one time where I opened up the
closet door and inside the closet was
the inside of an elevator yeah got in it
knows buttons that went all the way down
to like 200 miles down underneath the
ground yes and then when I got out I was
in a 70s apartment somewhere without
anyway yeah yeah like but it's like so
it anytime a movie can like successfully
convey that type of [ __ ] you know what I
mean
I mean seriously House of Leaves is one
of my favorite books of like the last
several years just because I mean it's
basically it's about this house and
these people go in there to like
investigate and it keeps getting bigger
on the inside like get on me like they
have like they find this staircase going
down and it just keeps going you go what
they're like camping out I know it's a
book okay and so there's that and then
there's like another narrative in the
camp and out and [ __ ] I've had dreams
like that yeah that's what I mean it's
very dreamlike right and there's also
like another narrative going on it's
like a meta-narrative and it's like kind
of like in the margins and like down of
the moor it's like somebody else
it's like commenting on this thing that
they found like about these reports
about the people going into the house
and like disappearing it's down and it's
so it's just like this big I kind of
want to see it turned into a movie but I
don't know how they would write because
I mean novels you can do a lot more
complicated [ __ ] than you can do in a
movie it's like I'm not really sure how
they would pull that off and it would
still be good right because in a book it
like it's super creepy and it like works
really well but
like in a movie it might just be dumb
I'm not really sure yeah maybe somebody
could do it but like I said this this
might be a thing I mean House of Leaves
might have to be a [ __ ] series second
so because it's the Halloween show
someone in the YouTube comments
suggested that why don't we do history
of Halloween or like just kind of like
urban legends around Halloween like [ __ ]
like that I was like yeah why haven't we
done that so I guess we decided we were
gonna do a little bit of that on this
show too cuz like I said we're doing
like a whole variety of things you think
you can I can handle it okay I'm ready
to handle it you're ready to handle it
ready yeah
okay I'm like you're gay as a Red Bull
and tequila it's a stimulant and a
depressant at the same time time I know
right so he's like a speedball yeah so
Halloween where did it come from
most people are probably aware that most
of the you know traditions around
Halloween and stuff like that date from
the ancient Celtic festival of saman how
ancient was that about 2,000 years ago
okay or give or take that's what they
say and you know the Celts they lived
mostly in Ireland and other parts of the
UK parts of northern France [ __ ] like
that
so Sawin initially was kind of there so
that was like the end of their year
because it was kind of like marks the
end of the harvest period let the end of
the summer and it was kind of like the
day where you knew that the winter and
the cold weather was coming and you know
what I mean so it was kind of like that
transitional type of period now because
of this transition the belief arose
among the Celts that the boundary
between the worlds of the living and the
dead was most porous at this particular
time of the year so on the night of
October October 31st they would
celebrate Sawin and on this night like I
said it was kind of like that was when
you know the dead could
communicate with the living more easily
there was all that other kind of [ __ ] so
the spirits they thought could do [ __ ]
like damaging crops and low causing
other kinds of problems but it also you
know on the other hand made it easier
for living people to communicate with
people on the down the other side so you
could get like kind of predictive powers
because you could ask the dead what was
going to happen so you could like
predict the future
there was also kind of some [ __ ] about
and this might have come about a little
bit later on but there was some kind of
stuff where women would do kind of stuff
to like predict like who their husbands
were gonna be or like you know that kind
of stuff to you but they were also kind
of predicting the future how the crops
rose that you know where the crops gonna
be good next year like [ __ ] like that
because you could ask dead people about
it because they were supposedly like
right there kind of midsummer stuff and
yeah and stuff from that old movie with
what's-his-name in it which one you know
what's his name what wicker man yeah
wicker man he's my drop there's another
t-shirt right there well it's just like
most of the time kind of notes after I
had that motifs after I had that head
injury when I was in the army and
everything you know she knows she knows
that I forget that the personal names of
people a lot but she knows what I'm
talking about I was like that thing and
this and her and him and she does what
I'm talking about
well it's like both the time well plus
two because it's like we've been
together so long so when you be like
that thing with the deal and I'm just
like doing well because I can
extrapolate from like what we were
talking about before and I know how your
mind works so I figured that that's
probably where your mind went to you so
I figured that by my worstest symbols
symbols yeah so I figured I knew that
words like because I was talking about
folk or yeah and you knew that it wicker
man
so I knew wicker man was probably the
first thing that you thought because
that was like a very mid summer because
I knew you were talking about mid summer
though
it gets worse as I drink it really does
yeah it's like let's go yeah we'll be at
the club somebody would walk in that I'd
know and I know that [ __ ] name I'll
go what's his name
yeah he has a remember anybody in chance
or a minute or she has to remind me of
the name oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just
like please don't
yeah it's not gonna be like hey guy yeah
and it's not it's not disrespect it's
it's just the inability to remember a
person it's like little like his brains
like Swiss cheese yeah no it's not like
sushi reminds like oh yeah and there
were me that's right I'll remember it
for that whole night it's kind of like a
performance anxiety or something or like
you're in the men's room trying to take
a leak and there's something you can't
it's exactly what it's like with
something when you put when I see
somebody I know it puts me under
pressure and I forget that person's name
I had that every now in them but usually
I'm pretty good at remembering right
usually but here's the thing
I was like that before that motorcycle
wreck yeah it got worse after yeah yeah
yeah I'm sure that didn't help we didn't
have I got worse house so I so sometimes
when we're out I feel like the human
rolodex because yeah I have to like our
labels names yeah I'm still like off of
and I'm drunk to you but I have to like
sit there and pop up like every right
should I have to remember the names of
all my I sure remember their names of
all his friends to like remember where
everything is I feel like remember not
to leave [ __ ] every I remember turn damn
stove oh I can remember to turn the
stove on after like it's very tiring
disabled veteran like I said hey for a
reason I know it really it's not a
[ __ ] disability no I know but it it
is kind of like it is very stressful
sometimes because I feel like I cover
everything because I have to remember
everything for two people and here's the
weird thing
if I forget your name doesn't don't for
a second thing that I forgot about you I
know everything that we said I know
everything about you I remember
everything about you is that better than
ninety exact I remember cyclist names
understand names they're forget our
animals names
and then soon as surah mozzie is just
booming I totally remember it's like now
and I'll remember it from then on out
until the next day yeah something about
sleeping and then waking up actually it
like stitches everything back together
yes yeah your brain is a mysterious
place you said do some she's seen it do
some weird [ __ ] to it has yes yeah so I
was young and stuff yeah yeah Karl's
young you'll know I'm gonna say it like
a white boy Jeong Jeong like Jenga vamos
a Mississippi stop you and I was talking
about that's something I was coming from
the unconscious yeah
it's where the blows comes from yeah I'm
sure yeah I'm sure oh I know yeah Karl
had some paranormal [ __ ] happened he saw
ghosts once he started out do you know
like and we were talking about this the
other day because I just saw a video a
couple days ago where someone was
talking about they were reinterpreting
the shining from a young in standpoint
the red books and they pointed out that
in almonds office yeah it what appeared
to be a copy of Carl Jung's red book
which hadn't been published at that
point but some people did know about it
because it was like unpublished for a
long time like yeah well tony is call
Jung's unconscious yeah that's younger
tony is the one that shows you things
yeah in my case my version of tony was
the one that moved things
yeah it's but it it shows me things too
if you read the book that we wrote you
know yeah together but yeah it shows me
things too and I have feelings about
things it does it is in the unconscious
the thing that interested me about and I
didn't really like and we've talked
about this before but I didn't really
like the shining miniseries that came
out in 1997 it was actually Stephen King
like oversaw it but McGary started
um it was a lot closer to the book but I
didn't like it as much probably for that
very reason even though I like to look
very much but one thing that they did in
the miniseries that they didn't do in
Kubrick's version of the movie was that
Toni was a an apparition like he was a
person like she did classism like he
would be floating there off in the
distance and then they reveal at the end
spoiler alert that Tony is actually
Danny grown up yes so that's like an
older version of him yeah yeah like
telling yeah so in that way you can see
in a more Jungian like I mean I like
Kubrick's version like as a film version
I like Kubrick's version better with
like the finger I like that better yeah
just because it's what because I feel
like in the book it works better to have
like oh he's an apparition of like his
older self or whatever like that's fine
like on the page but in the movie it
looks cheesy yeah so just like the hedge
animals look cheesy in the movie yeah
you know what I mean it's cool in a book
when you imagine it yeah but then when
you actually see it in front your face I
think in terms of young I think maybe
Tony floating in the sky and the older
version of him you know was was Tony I
think I think young probably called it
the anima maybe or the animus yeah yeah
I think that it was something like that
and I would probably call it what they
the day moan yeah you should read you
you should read day-long Philip
Pullman's his mark His Dark Materials
trilogy because that was the whole thing
we're like people where people had like
they had demons they had like an animal
there was like a manifestation of their
soul essentially yeah and it was like
outside of them like they could like it
was their Friday or for people who don't
know we're talking about your imagine
this you're playing a video game
alright you got a little character run
around on a screen alright do you think
that that little character is you let's
say let's say that that cares like an
appetizer
you all right you're at
and that's you that's all you know is
that little character in that screen but
then all of a sudden that character and
the screen realizes that he's just a a
video image and that there's a player on
the other end and that video that video
character turns around and looks at you
through the screen and sees you playing
him
well who's who the real you is the
player not the [ __ ] video game
character I would argue that there isn't
even a real you yeah a real does it
the Dame on you on those on those damn
video controls is the real you the
character in the video game is not you
right now in this world were the video
game characters our de mons are the real
us in another dimension playing this
game hmm okay this is a simulation
that's how I'm looking at like the
matrix that's how I think it is yeah
well kind of like the matrix but yeah so
you're Damon so Tony would have been his
Damon yeah okay the guy who was really
in control [ __ ] was a symptom is showing
him stuff yeah well it was like a future
version of himself right where's like
like I got that I don't even remember
like I read the book not too long ago
like I reread it but it's like I don't
even remember if he went super into that
but the UM I'm assuming that was what he
meant because that's what he put in the
miniseries yeah I like that idea on the
page I just didn't like it so much in
the movie I thought I was chasing what
well you couldn't shoot it the right way
that's what I mean there's no way
there's nobody to do that it's much a TV
series like I said horror works much
better simpler I liked simpler and more
ambiguous and lists she loved the
Kubrick movie I loved the book I like
the TV series yeah you like I like them
all I didn't mind it I just thought it
wasn't like the first time I saw it I
hated it I couldn't even finish it you
see how he's click you can't compare the
TV series to the movies they're two
totally different animals yeah it's two
different things it's change totally
different animals well like I said the I
mean
the Kubrick movie yeah he just basically
took the frame of the novel yeah and
built his own vision on it which you
know that's good it's a classic it is
that novel but it's from the point of
view of what it would look like in the
material world without all that spirit
that's what I mean without all the [ __ ]
and that's what I liked about it here
I liked the distance yeah because you
were seeing what would happen if you
wait they were there all right seeing it
happen like you didn't have access to
like people's inner thoughts you didn't
have nothing like that you were just
seeing you know exposition no we didn't
have any kind of psychic ability
writings happening in the spirit world
and you would never do you think about
scariest you would just see some
apparitions and some weird [ __ ] and Jack
going crazy yeah that's what I mean and
that's much scarier - yeah it's not
explained he's God explained the problem
with the miniseries like I said I don't
have a problem with it a book because
when you're writing a book you have to
essentially create a world in someone's
head so you have to explain things you
have to do exposition you have to things
like that but in a movie I think it's
much scarier to leave it ambiguous where
like you don't know what people's and
her thoughts are you don't know you know
I mean it's much scary to leave the way
series was not scary but it was a lot
more accurate to the it was that was one
thing I've given once you show
everything about the book the tone has
to change
yeah and there was something kind of
like frighteners yeah alright and that's
what it was like it was kind of like
something like the old movie Fridays
which I like the frighteners the
frighteners was I thought I was a
[ __ ] awesome movies kind of like the
Paranal burl version of this slurring
version of [ __ ] Back to the Future
really the dark back to the future I
liked it yeah
you just be very difficult to get the
same tone as the book into a TV series
that shows I mean it's two completely
different mediums it's just not a work
that's a completely different mediums if
you want to know what it if you want to
know the tone of the book but in visual
sense you got to go for the movie
yeah but if you want the substance of
the book envisioned in a visual medium
you got to go to the dam but like I said
the miniseries was very literal to the
world which some people might like that
better but I didn't like that because
like I said it's two different mediums
they don't work the same it's time for
them to redo the stand just say it I saw
the TV version of the stand and the time
that it came out it's okay but revisit
it and I was like man it's all watchable
well it's very dated very dude very
dated it's just kind of like the 1990
yeah it which is good but it's dated in
a lot of ways yeah okay so where were we
now we kind of get off about the shining
[Laughter]
is some from our childhood so and it's
one of those things that like is open to
multiple interpretations yeah there's
something about that movie that kind of
affected our generation I think some of
the younger people kind of liked the
movie and they seem to like it last time
do they show it in the theater well yeah
like I said it was kind of fun yeah and
like I said I do feel like you know as
much on you know we're old people now so
it's like I don't do this but I don't
feel like but you know a lot of people
like [ __ ] on Millennials and [ __ ] on
[ __ ] like that but it does seem like a
lot of them appreciate [ __ ] from the 70s
and 80s maybe even more than [ __ ] that
comes out seeing about later
Zoomers seem to like it even more yeah
yeah I I definitely have felt like that
there's like kind of a constant like
appreciation of that kind of [ __ ] so
especially among the horror community
like I said because and I think I
mentioned this before but the horror
community does seem much more in general
it does seem much more open to stuff
from different eras yeah and not like
judging stuff it's like oh this came out
so like oh it's so old or something like
that because I mean even when I was a
kid we can go back and look at nas rot -
well that's what I mean even when I was
a kid growing up in the 70s and 80s even
I liked [ __ ] that came out in the 20s
the 30s the 40s it's like you know I was
oh that's so old I can't like that it's
like there's something to like from like
every decade one of the one of the best
[ __ ] horror movies of all times and
still kind of creepy out in a way was
the black cat from 1920s aboard Bela
Lugosi
and honestly glassy fly weird-ass movies
I loved I have a whole series on my blog
if you guys have not read it about
silent movies I love the vibe of silent
movies because there's something like
otherworldly about them there's no audio
it's like they feel like they came from
a different dimension a little bit
because it was so long ago um and they
definitely have like this really creepy
like atmosphere that I don't think will
ever be replicated although you know I
do feel like in the 90s they did it with
a little bit with forgotten where he
tried to kind of make it look like that
but I mean if you've seen like the 1920
was I can't remember what year was but
it was like early 1920s they did a we
are really weird like a surrealistic
adaptation of the Fall of the House of
Usher
and they did like all these really cool
like optical effects like with all these
weird staircases like kind of going over
so it was like visually like really cool
looking it looked like a really cool
like goth video except in the 20s and
it's like the fact that people were
doing that back then I don't know it's
like I could always appreciate that on
care if it's old I don't care what
you're it's from visually the cabinet of
dr. Caligari we it was awesome it's by
today's standards long and boring movie
but visually the way they did [ __ ] in
this style it is I love that German
Expressionism I still love that I love
that whole you know they were all into
like the psychoanalysis and they were
all into kind of like we're we're like
the reason they call it Expressionism
it's like we're expressing like what the
interior of your mind like looks like on
the exterior like it's all like warped
and show yeah so it's like I really
really like that aesthetic I'm always
like that if you want to go back and see
if [ __ ] weird ass movie it's a talkie
see the black cat with Boris Karloff and
Bela Lugosi you could probably watch it
for free on YouTube and there's zillions
like recommend for men yeah that movie
was ahead of his time sexiest [ __ ] -
bunch of Satanists
that's my me before the haze go yeah
Satanists and weird necrophilia but even
it's like there was a bunch of like I
mean look at like Todd Browning's freaks
which came out in the 30s or like cat
people that came out in the 40s it's
like there's all kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
back then that's like still good now if
you watch it nowadays idea but you know
like I said I think I feel like horror
fans like real horror fans not just like
casual horror fans are kind of more open
to [ __ ] that's older because you can
appreciate [ __ ] in the context of the
time that it came out you know I'm
saying which i think is kind of
important when you're approaching kind
of any work of art you need to know like
the context around the time that it came
out yeah to appreciate it fully you
don't have to but you know I mean
seriously one of my favorite horror
movies of all time the haunting that
came out in 1963 still scary as [ __ ] and
they don't show anything which I think a
lot of like I don't remember that one
recent Harvey's well it's based on the
Shirley Jackson novel haunting of Hill
House which obviously they made into a
necklace series later on which was very
successful and was also very good
although that kind of deviated from the
novel a little bit but I didn't really
mind that much because it was kind of in
the spirit of the novel but the haunting
was directed by Robert Wise and it was
like the quintessential example well
it's my favorite haunted house novel of
all time of all time easily but the cool
thing about the movie is that it took
the spirit of the novel and it's just
like it did it exactly like on the
screen they're like we're not gonna show
anything like startled is no apparitions
in it there's no like like demons
popping out of the mirror is nothing
like that but everything they did in the
movie it was all atmosphere was only
cleared angles it was all like Oh a
doors breathing it's like all this like
really subtle [ __ ] but it was like
really really really scary haunting a
hill how still kind of stands up
it was a haunting of Hell House was
actually it was based on a Richard
Matheson novel it was kind of like the
haunting of Hill House but like almost
like a more I don't want to say camp
because that sounds bad but it's like
almost like a more you know overt
example of that but it was similar was a
similar vibe I mean I like that as well
and the book is great they had little
gothic witchy hotties and [ __ ] their
investigators and weird sexual [ __ ]
happening and a [ __ ] creepy old house
and the Belasco house yeah yeah yeah to
be honest that movie with Roddy McDowall
and every week I said that is I believe
it kind of [ __ ] hard to top in a
certain way in you know if you had to
ask me like to narrow it down because
for like I said people assemble I go I
don't like and it's not glory I'm like
what kind of horror movies you talking
about there's a million different kinds
not gory not a whole lot happens in it
[ __ ] in terms of people getting
killed but it's just creepy ass movie
yeah it's kind of like a prototype of
the evil I mean remember the movie with
yeah well I really like that movie some
people say that I'm and this is the only
movie it's on to be yeah you want to
watch it for free I'm just telling ya I
have some more recommendations for TV
movies later on you don't need a lot of
special effects see you don't and like I
said cast and you need good acting my
female I think that the problem and like
I said I'm not [ __ ] on special
effects I'm not [ __ ] on CGI it can
be done well yeah but the problem is you
can't rely on it horror does not come
from that no horror
ultimately I think comes from ambiguity
from not knowing something like mystery
is scary well you know what else it
comes from ultimately it comes from
acting well because the the actors have
to be able to deliver that yeah to where
you believe it and and smell than to and
soundtracked has a lot to do with it
oh yeah sure it has a lot to do with it
and I think I mentioned that before when
we were talking about the lighthouse
because I said I think I've I think a
lot of people don't realize how much
audio not just score but just like the
whole audio like design of a movie that
like gets you effects because seriously
why is it that if you're watching a
horror movie it's scary like people turn
it down yeah
why is that because it's like the sound
that's what that's all right exactly
it's a that's what's scaring you was
like the sound of him looking back on it
when I was a kid the movies that [ __ ] to
be at the worst really is because the
damn music yeah
that's what the music of the sound like
I said if you turn it down it's not
scary not always but like in a lot of
cases that that is true because unless
it was deaf we can put those horror
movies on the wind effect and they
wouldn't affect that's it well that
would make me sad it's like I'm gonna
snow because that's where the emotions
coming from is all that and like I said
I think we were talking about the
shining before I mean that if that's a
scary movie on its own but like I think
the the audio of the soundtrack of it
really like contributes to and David
Lynch knows this very well too I mean he
is super into like the sound design of
his movies and stuff and I think that
that really makes because he always has
these like weird like droning sounds
like you don't really notice that I'm
like no but yeah it's like but it's in
the back year mind like the whole time
and it's just like unsettling you and
like freaking you out like the whole
time so he's like very aware of that
kind of [ __ ] so I think that's a good
thing like to company you know it's a
good thing to approach and like come out
but I was gonna say to that what I was
saying before and that's a real like a
really good example of why you you don't
have to show a lot like to make it like
I said that's why you know you don't
need a big like budget or anything like
that like I said acting and it's
probably the most important thing
because if you buy that these people are
in this situation and they're scared
then you will buy into the premise no
matter how outlandish it is haunting a
Hell House the evil the legacy what else
the movies there along that same line
The Changeling The Changeling
burnt offerings burnt offerings right
there wasn't any real [ __ ] gore
special effects in them but they just
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me
yeah that's my kid I mean and I can
watch them now and they're still awesome
yeah they're still awesome
I like gore I do yeah yeah but you don't
need it but you don't need it you don't
really do it I mean
that's what I'm saying it's like okay so
they made the haunting in 1963 which is
a black-and-white movie based on
haunting of Hill House for Shirley
Jackson creepy as [ __ ] and like I said
it was all there was no gore in it there
was no ghosts in it there was nothing
like that
it was just it was all atmosphere it was
all acting it was all like these weird
like creepy angles that they have like
shadows that maybe there was something
there but she couldn't quite tell so it
was all like this ambiguity which was
very much in line with the book they
remade the movie in 1999 with [ __ ] I
wouldn't Wilson was in it Catherine
zeta-jones was that Liam Neeson was in
it
Lili Taylor was in it I love her but um
it was uh let me be diplomatic about it
was it was not good it was it was [ __ ]
actually and this the thing about it I
try to be diplomatic I just couldn't but
it's like the thing about it whoever
remade it and I don't remember who maybe
it was yonder bond I can't remember but
whoever remade it they're like okay well
we're just gonna make this as standard
paranormal investigators like they're
you know investigating a haunted house
type of deal so it's like let's see how
much CGI we can cram into this [ __ ]
movie and it's like you know I mean it's
like I read a whole blog post better
because I was so mad and I was just like
look they made like a spider look like a
bed they made like all this they don't
like a [ __ ] dragon hit it was it was
ridiculous it's just they just went like
way the [ __ ] is coming out the new
version god damn that might be good now
see we have seen the bridge I'm assuming
I haven't looked at anything up about it
there's a new movie coming out I think
it's coming out in January we've seen
trailers for a couple times yeah
and it's called the turning the turning
and I'm watching it's got like fin
wolfhard
from stranger things is in it and what
and the actress is Senate playing the
nanny I've seen her she's in the new
Terminator movie too I think
yeah but I camera but her name is so
she's in this and I'm watching the
preview going this looks just like turn
of the screw it looks like the innocence
which was based on turneth scream scared
as [ __ ] at me was it was scared that's
still a scary movie yeah like I said
those based on Henry James turn the
screw so I'm watching it I'm like
looks just like that some of this must
be a new adaptation and then I see that
it's called the turning so I'm assuming
that that's what it's gonna be
it looks good but it it looks good in a
way that it could go either really
really right or really really we're
gonna go Michael Bay yeah see that's
what's bothering me but that's what's
selling now not necessarily I mean
they're looking for the Bucks
I mean midsummer did really well and
look how weird that may be actually
midsummer that I think bombs in it well
I'm not well critically it did really
incredibly and like it got a lot of good
buzz yeah but I think at the box office
in terms of money I don't think
midsummer I'm not sure how much it costs
to makes even though I appreciated
midsummer and a lot of guys that I saw
that I listened to that did reviews of
that on YouTube they [ __ ] they hated
that movie but weird yeah I liked
hereditary measure they're not the
Zionists hasta midsummer was awesome
midsummer is what you listen to if
you're gonna sit around this in the
[ __ ] death and June or that's what I
mean yeah death and June or [ __ ]
current 93 listen to David Tibet you
know I mean with all that [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] Germanic killing Germanic Celtic
[ __ ] Reagan istic goth type you know
well here's the thing too it's like look
I've been into horror movies since birth
Pro look what is for as long as I can
remember like because my parents were
you know very lackadaisical
lackadaisical but they don't really like
care if I watched our movies or not so I
started watching horror movies at a very
young age so I like all kind of horror
movies I like stupid gory slasher movies
like just dumb [ __ ] I like super
intellectual horror movies I like you
know so I like a big wide variety so it
always like I don't know it always kind
of bothers me when people are like if
like if you only like one kind of horror
movie like I only like slasher movies or
I only like monster movies Rose it or
whatever that's fine but I do feel like
you're missing out on a lot of [ __ ] if
you're not willing to watch weirder [ __ ]
or like more like intellectual [ __ ] cuz
a lot of times I feel like I like
monster movies I like slasher movies
they're fun to watch but then you forget
about them like a week later I'm like
did I even see that like yeah I think I
saw that I don't really remember
anything about it but when I see
something like hereditary when I see the
only midsummer when I similar with the
lighthouse or the witch or something
like that it's like in years later I
still remember that [ __ ] like I still
remember images from it I still remember
like how it made me feel and stuff so I
think that was far more successful as a
movie because I remember it many years
later because I see horror movies all
the time I watched them several of them
a week most of them are fine and I enjoy
them while I'm watching them but most of
them I don't even remember if I watched
them like a couple weeks later I'd be
like I don't even remember if I saw
matter did I see that yeah I guess I did
you know what I mean but I don't
remember anything about it yeah yeah see
we're getting we're getting sidetracked
on this Halloween [ __ ] we get
sidetracked by these [ __ ] moves we
got to go back to the Halloween legends
we do Halloween but I mean the thing
about it is that I mean you know horror
movies that's still Halloween [ __ ] yeah
and like I said we will get to be able
like stories and show like that
eventually that'll probably be like the
second half of the show we're gonna read
everybody's stories for us that means
we're gonna do it tomorrow probably
probably well like I said we're gonna
record this over a couple of days cuz
like there's a lot of drinking for us to
do it one time yeah we can all edit it
together into a good show though people
will people enjoy it we've been talking
[ __ ] all night pretty much yeah it's
like some of it we can't leave yeah so
every time so so we were talking about
Halloween history right yeah so I was
talking about Halloween has a history
well there's a history the hello
everything has a history you have a
history yeah I have a history exactly
I'm sure yours is much more exciting
than mine yeah well you had a lot more
things happen yeah you you're the you're
the Artur you're the artist and a writer
that brings all this [ __ ] to fruition
talk about that [ __ ] on my
interesting [ __ ] you know you you put
things together that people actually buy
that's true you know I mean products
that people buy and enjoy and it affects
them I'm not creator in that way
yeah it's like well it's interesting
because well it's like I said that's an
interesting thing to me too it's an
interesting dynamic because I I mean you
know I have a life I like do stuff
outside of it some but a lot of my life
has lived in my imagination yeah
and in my head yeah and you're making my
thinking a [ __ ] that I can do and like
thinking a different [ __ ] I can do it's
it's just interesting like yeah
interacting with someone it's more
external where I was almost entirely
internal ya know I like to make [ __ ]
happen
why do too but actually happen it's most
of it's coming from in I'm yes I miss
that [ __ ] that part of me that went
out and [ __ ] [ __ ] up I'm talking about
I mean you send me that damn comic book
cover sell [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] are and what you do shows up on the
news yeah buddy else is talking about it
[Laughter]
so are you so so we were talking about
Halloween history yeah I mean like I
said we we're getting the horror movies
were getting all kind of [ __ ] and like I
said we'll read people's stories Joe
like that's it
like I said that we have no plan for
this we're just we have like the plan is
in the Edit yes I have like a bunch of
different [ __ ] like indifferent like
note things like in my notebook and like
on the screen and [ __ ] like that but I'm
just gonna like edit it together I'm not
worrying about it right now yeah because
I just can't worry about it
so alright so where was I with the
Halloween history so we're talking about
the Celts we're talking about the Sawin
we're talking about how that was like
the transition between kind of the
summer the harvest season and then like
the shitty like cold weather where
nothing was gonna
been like everything every woman have to
be like inside and [ __ ] but also there
was like the the you know the veil
between the living in the dead was more
porous you could like the two sides
could contact one another for good or
for ill that's also they think we're the
whole costume thing came about because
apparently and this might have come
about a bit later but there might have a
thing where there was like some people
that were dead and maybe a living person
did something bad to them murdered them
or just like [ __ ] them over somehow
before they died and so you know since
the veil between the two between the
living and dead was so thin some people
were worried that like some dead people
might come back like looking for some
supernatural whoop-ass like getting a
little bit of revenge something like
that so people were like well I'm gonna
wear a costume so [ __ ] won't recognize
me from like beyond the grave right so
you know and I said cuz you know no one
wants to get their ass kicked by someone
that's like coming from beyond the grave
raise your right cuz they don't probably
kick your ass yes they have like
super-handsome hours getting your ass
kicked from beyond the grave right it it
happens yes so they think baby that's
where the whole costume thing kind of
came from people like wearing masks that
they wouldn't be recognized by dead
people that they had maybe [ __ ] ever
when they were still alive so you know
back then they didn't have like [ __ ]
Party City or nothing so they're just
like they're wearing like animal skins
and like animal skulls and heads and
things like that so there was also whole
thing was like bonfires and all this
other kind of stuff for the sacrificial
whatnot so then comes a rat about 43 AD
the Roman Empire comes along conquers
most of the Celtic territories now they
ruled the Celtic lands for about 400
years now during this time during this
four hundred year period there were a
couple of Roman festivals also that kind
of got tied up with the whole saw one
celebration and kind of would later go
on to morph into our more modern
Halloween traditions that we see
nowadays
now there was a festival in the Roman
Empire that was called fur alia which
was a day in late October and that was
kind of like a traditional Roman holiday
where they would commemorate you know
dead be like people that had passed on
and then the second festival was a day
to honor their goddess Pomona who was a
Roman goddess of fruit and trees whose
symbol was the Apple so they think that
maybe this might have been where the
whole Association I mean yes apples are
in season and fall so that might have
been a factor also but you know this
might have been where the whole apple
bobbing thing came it's like you know
apples having to do with Halloween and
whatnot so that's probably where that
came from from the Roman kind of a
tradition of the goddess of Pomona now
in 609 BCE or ad if you prefer
there was one of your Pope's Pope
Boniface Boniface Boniface that's Bob
Boniface the forth so he decides as they
did and they did this with Christmas and
Easter also they said well Christian
shits gonna take over so we're just
gonna take all your pagan holidays and
we're gonna incorporate it so you can
still celebrate your pagan holidays but
we're gonna say it's for something else
now so that's pretty much what they did
with the Celtic Festival of sawa and all
that type of like similar thing they
said okay we're gonna take this day over
we're gonna say that November 1st is All
Saints Day all martyrs day whatever so
we're gonna celebrate like all the
Christian martyrs
so then hat as it turned out like the
night before that is All Hallows Eve the
day before All Hallows day
so that would be hallow Eve hallow
evening Halloween so that's where the
name came now as it happened so by the
time wait a minute hold on
[Music]
okay where was I okay so ninth century
comes around Christianity is kind of
like spread all throughout the Celtic
lands and it kind of like kind of
blended into and took over a lot of the
old Celtic traditions kind of like made
it their own type of thing and maybe
people back then because they didn't
have the internet or Google or nothing
like that but it's like maybe they just
thought that's how [ __ ] was because you
couldn't like look [ __ ] up from back in
the right you don't even from back in
the old days it was just it was kind of
just like a slow evolution worthy yeah I
mean Christianity started to kind of
take over and they just said oh well
this day has always been the fest for
this and people like okay sure no the
Church the Catholic Church is highly
organized so they knew how to like
assimilate mm-hmm non-credit
non-christian traditions into their own
they would say oh yeah this day that you
believe in there that exists but you
know Mary's behind that yeah we're gonna
like like we're gonna climb some other
[ __ ] and I think I have no regenerations
are gonna retrofit it nobody noticed
this you don't think they did it no I
mean they did do it there's a lot of
stuff that happens yeah
with Germanic cultures in Christianity a
lot of the German German ik p 'pls had
germanic interpretations of christianity
you know and so i don't think it was as
a big of a clash as people tend to think
well because it was a very slow
evolution like he says and it wasn't
like I mean like I said when one
generation would die and like the next
generation will come it's not like they
could look [ __ ] up like a Googler but a
lot of people were illiterate so it's
not like they could be like oh well a
hundred years ago this was a pagan
festival called Sawin people didn't know
I have history and they did it right
that's what I mean so it's it's kind of
like no formalizes really yet that type
of like continuation like you would get
nowadays where you know so it was much
easier for that I'm not saying they did
they didn't do it on purpose because
they did but I don't think they
had like a long term plan for you know
the most educated people probably in
Europe at this time be people associated
with the Catholic Church right and even
they didn't know everything
back up at the Vatican they might have
all the books you know I mean that could
explain everything but I guarantee you
there weren't very many people reading
those books yeah because there was some
badass [ __ ] that back in the 1500s the
1400s where Catholic priests were
sending back the entire huge books about
the Aztecs and the Mesoamericans
cultures and their religions they would
send that back to the Vatican so they
could assimilate that knowledge those
books were never read yeah because the
priests didn't care they had other [ __ ]
they had to worry about yeah so there's
a lot of stuff that was just kind of
lost because people didn't care they
were just dealing with the present yeah
not so much the past and you know I'm
not you know whatever whatever so
alright so the celebration of Halloween
as we know it nowadays probably came to
the probably came to colonial America
with the Irish immigrants because they
were the ones that still kind of
celebrated it in a way so at the time
there was kind of like a clash between
cuz that was kind of mostly a Catholic
celebration cuz you have like a lot of
Protestants also in New England they
weren't they didn't take too kindly to
that type of thing so they didn't really
wanna do they thought that was all
satanic and why not so there was kind of
some clash there so it didn't really
spread outward until later on although
it should be noted that because of the
influence of like you know Irish
tradition and like a Catholic tradition
in New England particularly in the early
you know colonial America you know they
were the ones that kind of brought the
stuff about it sort of evolved once they
got to the new continent it seems like
it more of
in a way of they wanted it to be more
kid based you know you know what I mean
so it's also kind of like they would
have these big like public events where
they were celebrating like the fall
harvest and [ __ ] then they would have
like you know kind of all people in the
neighborhood like getting together and
talking about what had died and stuff
like that um there was a there was a big
element of like fortune-telling because
like I said that was kind of a big thing
even going back to the old Celtic days
where you know women would be like oh
we're gonna like peel apples and like
you throw apple like apple peels over
your shoulder and like hope that it
would spell out like the initials of the
dude you were gonna marry ya with or
they would like do weird mirror games
like you know like a little bit like
Bloody Mary but not quite as like scary
where they would like look in the mirror
and be like I you know if I say the
right words like you know the face of my
husband will like appear behind me in
the mirror and [ __ ] like that yeah so it
was always divination type of games so
women were interested with it they were
mostly worried about who was gonna get
married well yeah they were gonna marry
yeah that yes so that was like a big
that was like a big thing in Halloween
because like I said they they it almost
seemed like a mediumship type of thing
because they said well well the dead are
like right there like on Halloween so we
can ask them [ __ ] what's gonna happen
them in the fridge and you have to think
too that like back in the old days if
you're a woman yeah it's like nowadays
you're you know you're a woman you can
do pretty much pretty much whatever you
want it's like you can have to who you
were managed back then yeah it's like
you couldn't get a job you couldn't like
have a bank account or nothing like that
so it's like it was like Who am I gonna
miss like Xena have money is he gonna be
a dick he's gonna beat me up yeah
you know I mean so it's like you really
had to worry about that guy it was kind
of like all they had to worry about
although you know back then average
[ __ ] didn't have a bank account
well no but I'm super rich people had
bank account we're talking about we're
talking my peasant women mm-hmm they
mostly wanted to know who they were
married for childish kind of reason well
it is this somebody that it not childish
it's work to go oh it's practical
there they were also thinking like what
are the babies gonna look like
look do they have a farm are they going
to work are they gonna be a drunk are
they gonna beat my ass I think you know
what I mean so they had practical
concerns well I would think that women
within their class were marrying men
within their class and they probably
yeah the men they were gonna marry
before they married they just wanted to
know which one because yeah how much
does this one suck
they might have been sure some of them
were chances are you talking about a
tent you taught my little bitty villages
in little bitty towns where as a girl
probably only had three or four guys
that could possibly marry her yeah so
she probably knew them all yeah it's not
the same good-looking girls yeah I mean
it's probably just like nowadays where
it's like if you're plain looking or a
little bit ugly or fat or whatever
you're not gonna have your pick but if
you were a good-looking girl you're
gonna get there Richie maybe had two or
three different suitors you could choose
from Sears like well how much money's is
this kind of a farm you know it is he
long enough to like give me children
they're gonna work on the foot you're
also talking about in a time when
dalories were involved and your dad was
the one yeah like how much how many
goats am I gonna get was your dad that
was really doing this business and you
were probably pushing your dad to go for
the youngest best-looking richest one
that was out there well yeah and chances
are you were already naming to your dad
pick this one or this one
yeah you get by name you know the man
and he was probably vying for those two
and trying to cut the deal because it
was a business transaction that's what I
mean yeah and even women back then and
the parents of the women would have very
practical concerns yeah
because back in those days you know not
necessarily but women could not have
jobs of their own they could have so
everything was passed through the man so
you had to be very super careful yeah
but Joseph won he also had a consider
that women couldn't have jobs because
there weren't jobs these are farming
feet
well now the wizard works on the farm
yeah everybody was everybody was waving
the kids did yeah there weren't really
jobs but so it wasn't like yeah wasn't
like oh I'm going to the office yeah we
didn't have that corporate America yeah
it wasn't like that so we got a beat we
got to be we got to be honest about what
this look like I said so you can
understand why they had a lot more
practical change back then it's like is
this dude young enough to give me a lot
of children Nick working on the farm is
he does he have money can he invest in
family powerful is his family parent is
he a drunk or what is he gonna like run
off and leave me is he gonna like leave
me to work alone is he gonna do this and
that the other accordingly most of the
things that I was able to [ __ ] read
do during these time periods though
things worked out kind of for for the
times I mean well yeah I mean most thing
that day link I think probably the
biggest difference between today and
then was the hygiene you're talking
about people that didn't have running
water
yeah I talked about people that didn't
have electricity yeah and that makes a
big difference in life you know now be
an ex-military I know what it's like to
live without that you can compensate but
it's just things were not very
convenient yeah you know and if you were
an in disciplined person or a person
from a [ __ ] [ __ ] kind of bad
background it's easy to be a filthy
[ __ ] under those circumstances
well it's easy to be a filthy
[ __ ] yeah nowadays it is on
water or you go down and get it much
easier back then yeah yeah and now it's
like there's not much excuse if you sit
down pull a thing right yeah but it's
all work then yeah and even how long how
to like hike down to the [ __ ] pub
right and then you have to eat your own
water so I can understand people down
there spring go [ __ ] it I'm not doing it
today yeah I can understand that but I
I'm of an opinion of based on personal
and reading that I kind of think that as
long as people weren't [ __ ] with you
people were very happy back then because
it's it was kind of a naturalistic life
style I don't know that and I think it
was very they didn't have the same
expectations of what you had today and
it was very family oriented and I don't
they didn't they didn't worry about
governments telling them what to do in
passing laws it all had to do with
families you know and not wanting to
dismount
everyone was worried about their
immediate circumstances the thing about
it though is that it was tribal to say
though because a lot of times people's
immediate sorry like if all they're
worried about it's their immediate
circumstances a lot of times
particularly if you works on a farm or
something like that the immediate
circumstances are not good that you know
what I mean there's always but it was
weather conditions are here so it and
it's [ __ ] that you can't control but it
was a simpler time they didn't explain
control [ __ ] but in another way - that's
like people's stress levels tend to be
much higher when they feel like they
can't control things so I do feel like
the fact that nature was kicking your
ass all the time or like [ __ ] you
couldn't do anything about was kicking
your ass all the time um I could see how
that would make you a lot more like
unhappy but they may have been because
you didn't have any but they may have
been tougher right maybe it didn't it
didn't bother than the Sam I don't even
know if I had so much call it tougher
but it's just they were just probably
beaten down by life because there's like
well this is how it's gonna [ __ ] be
and it's like there's nothing you can do
about it so it's like you would get to a
point where it's like you just quit
fighting it because it's like there's
nothing you probably I'm optimistic I'm
not pessimistic on that fact I was I'm
just being realistic about it I'm just
saying that's how I would react my time
in the infantry was a hard time but it
was still I loved it
yeah I mean I felt yeah you know so I
think it just depends on the situation
people that couldn't adapt died all
right yeah people that could were around
and they didn't they didn't bother them
I mean
and and I think I have a tendency to
think that in general as long as you
weren't being [ __ ] with I think those
old people were happy
maybe but like I said I wasn't there so
I think they were happy I
what would [ __ ] with you is invading
tribes of people or Kings trying to tell
you what to do and to make you a serf
and to force you to write to a land that
wasn't yours or you know I mean till
then you really didn't know you know I
mean II had to give all this [ __ ] up to
the king so I was I think governments
and proto governments and warlords
probably were really your main right the
fact though would be that you wouldn't
know like you would know that that
possibility was out there but you
wouldn't know when it was coming so I
feel like that uncertainty might also be
a stressor in itself well it might have
been like a situational situation
certain people in certain areas were
more susceptible to being funny because
you can never settle exactly because
it's like well what if this happened or
what if that had like there might have
been you know Russian Kulak type peoples
you know out in the middle of nowhere
who might live seven or eight
generations without any any contact you
know outside their [ __ ] family and
tribe you know what I mean
yeah but then there might have been you
know I mean so depending on the
situation yeah if I had people on the UH
on you know in Britain who are right
there near you know it's a smaller area
they're right there near a bunch of
warlords and Kings and they might be
being [ __ ] with but there were other
people out in Russia that didn't see
anything outside their own family for
many generations like I said I think it
would depend on the situation
yeah situation because if you were aware
of even like the next village over like
they [ __ ] with by someone like if you
knew the possibility that that might
happen then that would stress you out
and I and I feel like that would you
know kind of bite into your into your
happiness because you would feel like
well what if that happens here because
it happened
only a few miles away you're thinking
that you're looking this from a modern
person with it with the access to
history books and knowing the big
picture I think the average person had
no knowledge well yeah they would have
knowledge of what was going on in a
village or - oh yeah but that's about it
so if bad should happen there then they
would be aware that that could happen
there also and the so the possibility
would be open to them I'm just saying
that I you know I don't necessarily
think that I mean yeah ignorant as bliss
as they say but if you knew a family
member you knew a neighbor you knew
something that wasn't that far away from
you that it had some like [ __ ]
fucked-up [ __ ] happen to them and you
understood that that can happen to you
also then I think that would impact your
happiness level I have a feeling that
ignorance is bliss and in general people
were ignorant so I think yeah but they
weren't ignorant of everything no no not
everything just ignorant of what was
going on in the world scene sure you
know what am i [ __ ] up [ __ ] was
happening in a local yeah concept mom
girls may have been invading right I can
take it whole areas they didn't know
about so Y Delta well I don't know if
that was necessary was that information
and like I said if if the next village
over had gotten [ __ ] over by a disease
or by like invaders or that you would
know about that yeah so it's not like it
was something they didn't know about
weren't completely ignorant of that but
they would only be worrying about that
within their lifetime don't like things
didn't happen very quickly back then
yeah so and a lifespan wasn't that long
so they might have the average person
that living out in the [ __ ] boonies
on these towns may have only experienced
a couple different things in their
lifespan like yeah there was a plague
over there and 20 years before that you
know there was some guys that came and
[ __ ] captured some people we don't
know who they were
yeah there's a lot of that kind of show
the other thing too is that I think
humans have the tendency to concentrate
on the negative
so even if something happened 20 years
ago let's say like if something happened
to your like your grandparents
generation um they would still tell
stories about it so you would still have
urban legends about and maybe to even
been banished in the interim
so I do feel like that was something
that would impact your daily life like
stories about that like I said I don't I
don't think that was ever a time when
people were just completely blissful and
like unaware and you know happy about
everything I don't think that's ever
happened well I'm not really saying that
humans are not built for that humans are
it said and ice and it sucks and I hate
it but humans are I don't want to say
design because that's we're not designed
but um you know we're just kind of like
more apt to remember [ __ ] that's
negative because that's a survival
mechanism yeah but then though I I don't
think happiness is is a natural human
condition I just don't
well it sucks but it's I don't think
that's there's a lot of writings that
exist from the early history of you know
the United States back in the sixteen
and seventeen hundred's and there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] that was going on back
then you know it and they seem to be
kind of upbeat you know the writings
that have survived
ya know in general they're just yeah
they're you know they're they're kind of
like yeah yeah this happened did that
happen to know well you know yeah just
[ __ ] yeah oh they weren't all like that
like I like a lot of [ __ ] particularly
from like the [ __ ] colonial period
was a big huge [ __ ] bummer
cuz I did a whole [ __ ] class on that
[ __ ] and those people were just like
[ __ ] they were always complaining well
depends on what period that really I
mean you know you can read stuff that
came out of you know Benjamin Franklin
yeah bedroom Franklin [ __ ] sit there
and [ __ ] you and tell you all kinds
of cultures always him you know think
that that was realistic for his life
though I mean he would go down to France
and he'd knock down arsenic
was kind of just like he seemed like a
very I mean I didn't know the dude
obviously but um dude was cool man
he seems like a very upbeat like person
and I and I don't feel like a lot of
people were like that because I've read
other [ __ ] from people from that same
era and it's not like that well I think
it depended on your character in your
situation it's just like nowadays
there's optimistic wedlock and do all
kind of stuff yeah he was having a good
time he got out of France and go you
know knock down some French girls and
wear his [ __ ] little coats getting
hats and talk to a damn French King and
the aristocracy and he'd come back to
the United States and [ __ ] he's dick
slinger you know what I mean there are
some guys that are just like that
yeah dude take an air bath you know I
mean take he's a [ __ ] nudist and [ __ ]
I mean you know you're dealing with
chronic character but like I said but I
think he was an anomaly but you had to
understand that there was a but you
can't look at it this way there was an
environment for there was an environment
in which a [ __ ] like that could
happen yeah which means that it couldn't
have been all that bad I mean just like
today you can go down have a great time
in Vegas you can have a great time in LA
you know in LA you have a great time in
[ __ ] New York and there's still bad
[ __ ] happening and something I think it
was just like in some ways like today
there's no difference yeah in some what
I mean humans are the same some people
are optimists and people are pessimists
I think in general and this is a very
general statement but I think in general
people have evolved to be a little more
pessimistic there they've evolved to pay
more attention to negative type of
things just because it's a survival
mechanism
but that doesn't you know mean that some
people aren't optimists yeah and don't
see the best in everything oh my
goodness they do I'm gonna get Buddhist
with you you just say life is what you
make it
in life is some King life is what you
focus on yeah it in it in the most cases
that is true yeah I mean you know life
is gonna [ __ ] on you in various ways
but how you react to it is pretty much
all you can do about yeah so you have to
like think long and hard about how
you're going to react to it yeah because
that's kind of all you can do I mean you
know I mean you're just like a little
person and like so we were talking about
Halloween history yeah yeah and I was
talking about how the Irish immigrants
came here and brought all their like
traditions and [ __ ] like that
yes traditions and show yeah oh yeah
well I was watching a documentary about
it earlier and the interesting thing
about it is they said here's the funny
thing like I said you had the whole
catholic protestant thing which was
going on and then you had very early on
the Halloween traditions particularly
20s and 30s it was almost kind of like a
mafia protection racket in the sense of
trick-or-treat being it used to be like
a literal thing it's like kids would
come to your house and be like give me
some money or some candy or something
right or I will [ __ ] your [ __ ] up yeah
that is like a mafia thing which yeah it
was it was exactly like that yeah it's
like pea rate or all yeah at your house
or or set your house on fire whatever
they did in the 30s I'm sure it was
probably worse than whatever they do now
and then bad I'm sure what never well I
don't know was it I think was funny gays
but in in a wit like that's how kind of
like trick-or-treat evolved it was it
was essentially a protection racket that
involved into something like a lot more
late hearted it was like paranormal
protection racket will protect you from
the demons if you just give us some
pennies or some candy and where the
demons if whatever it is that you have
so yeah so that was where that whole
tradition came from and then after that
around the 1950s when everything started
to be more like family oriented and all
that kind of [ __ ] it kind of started
going more kid like directs you know
it's like you know it's more kid focused
and they can go trick-or-treating and
like the adult sniper anything to do
with anymore it lost it lost like a lot
of its pagan associations even though it
still had a lot of the pig and trappings
because you still had the whole
you know dressing up in costumes thing
because you didn't want like spirits to
recognize you know what not so you still
had that little thing going on but
that's where a lot of our traditions
came from as I said it's kind of like it
seems like it's almost kind of like I
mean yeah the whole like takeover of
Catholicism Christianity bla bla bla
that kind of like made it a lot more
widespread but it does seem like the
American tradition because it does seem
like we're kind of like the main country
that's up like yeah other countries
celebrate it but in America it's like
huge yeah you have to understand some
people American white people are mostly
Irish people we descended from well um
the Irish and they're like me they're
like [ __ ] 10 times as many Irish
people or in America than there are in
Ireland because once you let those
psychopathic Irish loose like this they
they reproduce in vast numbers [ __ ] yeah
we [ __ ] everything up and we kind of
take over and because without any rules
and you know did those [ __ ]
psychopathic gene G that psychopathic
genome that worked during that potato
famine that thrived over here you know
and that's why America is the way that
it is [ __ ] psyche that might be one
of the reasons yeah so a lot of the
Irish things and I would probably say
probably Scotland and to some extent
England that worked over here and it
proliferated and you know a lot of a lot
of the Irish descendants took on English
names to hide the fact that they were
Irish yes so not everybody not all you
know like my last name is Ross that
could be English or Irish but there were
other people that had Mick names you
know started with em see Mick all right
a lot of those vanished
change for English sounding names to
hide the fact that you were [ __ ] nuts
well yeah and the thing is it's weird
because back in the old days you know of
very early American immigration it seems
like America like Irish people were
almost seen like a different race yeah
yeah little monkey people is how they
were [ __ ] described a lot in the
newspaper it's very strange because now
I don't think people make that
distinction but back in the old days
because like I said my mom's side of the
family is Irish my dad said his family's
Native American so it's like I'm not
though as it was generally described by
the media back in that era the men
little monkey people the men good for
only thievery and crime yeah the women
only good for prostitutes like some yeah
like some job postings specifically said
no Irish yeah no Irish right but the
Irish proliferated and they didn't know
and a lot of Irish traditions like kind
of right particularly in New England but
they kind of like spread across bread
with everyone Anglo Americans that
crossbred with them Native American
Native Americans Afro Americans a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of black people actually
our part Irish they don't know it but
some of them do I've talked about them
but when you look at black people in the
United States a lot of them even going
back hundreds of years are biracial and
they're a mixture the white parts of
them are Irish and German yeah a lot of
German a lot a lot of German yeah
determinant well Norwegian influence
pretty good West I feel like that's kind
of a thing there aren't for the most
part some black people gonna [ __ ] you
know they're gonna love what I'm saying
because they know it's true other people
the other black people want to deny it
there aren't any real pure African
people to speak of in the United States
are all they're all part white well
everyone's mixed yeah everyone's kind of
I feel I mean everyone those born here
anyway they go out in New Orleans era
there
they're mixed a lot with the French but
you know everywhere else your black
people are part Irish part German yeah
and Jenny said that's cool this way it
is its way it rolled humans are humans
yeah really matter right it's just weird
that yeah and that's kind of the way it
happened so like I said there's kind of
a lot of particularly [ __ ] that came out
up and and I feel like the Irish had
like maybe like an influence far
surpassing their population numbers
maybe because they were so prevalent in
colonial America in that early period
you know the and then it kind of like
proliferated throughout the rest of this
also laundry mid-1800s era of the robber
barons yeah just use the Irish up our
railroad system is just littered with
dead the bodies of the dead Irish yeah
they'd pull them right out Chinese and
the dead Chinese two people right off
the boats and work him to death yeah
literally work them to death and then
there would be Irish uprisings in the
middle of this dam building these
railroads and corporate paid mercenaries
would just mow them down yeah there were
certain and and left unrecorded there
been times where on the sides of these
railroads they'd find like three to four
hundred yeah looking dead bodies on the
side of the day yeah because I mean
Irish even more than nowadays which you
know it's busy like you know you're just
a corporate cog or whatever it's like
Megan old days they would just like kill
you and like bury you in an unmarked
grave and even it wasn't a Singh racism
was part of it but you also have to
understand to some of the robber barons
were Irish it was more classism is more
like classism rate which is related in a
lot of ways but not always nothing no
not really [ __ ] you know the United
States is a ruthless place it was about
money and power and well Carnegie I
think was the was the Irish one and he
he killed a lot of his own here he did
yeah
they didn't really care about race that
much like more classic yeah some people
have said that black slaves were worth
something they were worth money
the Irish weren't worth anything yeah
they just [ __ ] it you can find Irish
just starve to death there were some
Irish people and indentured servitude oh
yeah right which was but an Germans -
yeah you had Irish slaves and the
English had Irish slaves back in England
I mean it wasn't to quite the same
extent or quite the same but there
wasn't that going nowadays black slave
is slavery
black slave loose nowadays black slave
slavery is remembered because it was
between well different races well and
because it was their widespread yeah it
was much more widespread and it was
agricultural slavery which is Dadis and
remember Irish slavery was different
because it was happening sometimes
between Irish people orbiting lished
enslaving Irish and it wasn't
agricultural and it wasn't always
permanent it was something some of them
were it was an indentured servant like a
debtor it was like something that like
you were supposed to like work for some
work your way out at the time until you
paid off whatever debt even though
reality of those days usually met you
died before you work your way out of it
because of disease and stories like I
said and in that sense it was a lot more
classes because it's like you know you
were kind of the bottom of the food
chain so like what are you gonna do like
you don't have any money and we do right
so yeah there's nothing you can do about
it the realities of history are far more
interesting than the [ __ ] myths of
history read your [ __ ] yeah really do
[ __ ] like I said it's always more
complicated it's more and I'll think
about it it's like I can't blame you
know history classes no because they
have a lot of [ __ ] to cover kind of like
what they have to simplify [ __ ] just so
people can learn the [ __ ] but it's like
yeah if you go into and I mean you
really have to like specialize in one
[ __ ] era if you really want to get
into it but everything ever is like much
more nuanced yeah if you're really
get history by today's standards and
[ __ ] put that back on the on what was
happening in the past we were all slaves
we were all [ __ ] slaves well all of
us that didn't have any money
yeah he didn't have any of mine you were
a [ __ ] slave pretty much yeah and
like I said no one's life was easy even
I mean people that had [ __ ] ton of money
comparatively their lives were very easy
yeah as they always are it goes on if
you don't have money and your life sucks
yeah always and forever land next to the
beginning of time and this went all the
way back to the Roman era that's what I
mean you know [ __ ] it the Roman
that's before recorded his yes the
Romans were all about status if you were
not a patrician then you were a [ __ ]
slave yeah yeah I mean it was looked at
you crazy if there was something wrong
with you if you had any kind of [ __ ]
physical abnormalities if you were of a
lower class then that meant that was on
you if you did them you did so they
didn't have me there was no concept of
equality and I mean the Roman and I feel
like there's still like a lingering
thing of that but I mean it's obviously
not as bad as it was but there's some
like a lingering thing where if
something's the matter with you like
you've like a birth defect right sample
yeah like people there's still like a
lingering thing where people think maybe
you did something to your baby but it's
like and that's bad but it's like a long
time ago it was way worse because
everyone believed that yeah heartedly
yeah like you were born with a [ __ ]
[ __ ] peg leg or a [ __ ] stomp her
leg foot or something like that because
your ancestors did some [ __ ] the gods
yeah so obviously your treat you like
crap but like you're walking down the
street and if you weren't more rich from
a patrician families as Casillas you
were it's because you were inferior
right you deserve and because your
ancestors were inferior yeah so the
whole concept of this whole thing that's
one of the great things about America
you know man the concept of
quality and that we are all human beings
and then we should all have equal access
to the law and the rules this is a
[ __ ] uniquely American concept really
yeah it doesn't work in practice but I
mean the concept is good back in our
ancestors that was just like whoa if
you're not if you're ugly it's because
you're [ __ ] up like the gods yeah
right yeah which they really stick they
were on yeah you're ugly so that means
you suck seriously so therefore I mean
shut like even my grandparents and
that's only two generations ago my
grandpa's were awesome but like even
they would say stuff like oh they got
hit with the ugly stick yeah and like
that and that was like a moral judgment
yeah like if you were born ugly yeah
then obviously what your ancestors were
ugly and your answers were ugly for well
then obviously there was something the
matter I'm so weakened as they weren't
as consequently they weren't as good as
pretty but we can treat you exactly as
your subhuman right yeah yeah and like I
said I feel like there's still like a
lingering factor of it and it's like
it's it's something that's hard to get
[ __ ] on histogram with these pretty
[ __ ] taking pictures of
themselves about how awesome they
[ __ ] are and their [ __ ] girls put
booties in the camera and you don't have
a booty like this it's that same
mentality very human thing
attracted to like attractive people
right that's what that's what it was but
I do feel like when when you make the
extent when you kind of go like the
further step and say what we you're
making a moral judgment against someone
because they're not as good-looking yeah
as someone else yeah then that is
problematic yeah well we're doing is
that we're taking it one step further
that's what I'm saying it we're pretty
and you're not pretty right and because
you're not pretty because you suck
because because yeah yeah yeah and then
they do the ground thing outside on a
pond you suck because the gods don't
like you right that's what they were
doing I mean and because the gods don't
like you
we don't like then I don't have to learn
I don't have like you and that means
we're gonna make you do whatever we say
right so the US Constitution and
Americanism and in a certain sense the
French to a certain way with the era of
enlightenment was to get away with that
to get away from that kind of [ __ ] and
to judge a human individual based upon
their behavior and so that's what that
was the new era of enlightenment which
that's a good thing it's a lot better it
is it's a lot better it's a lot better
because you can't seriously I've done a
lot of like good-looking people that
have [ __ ] it really sucked all the
[ __ ] but they were [ __ ] back
then that's the rain never hassles back
then
you can just get away with it like look
at this face that's the way it was
that's what I mean I'm pretty a [ __ ]
yeah and I got money
exactly I mean you can't do anything
about I'm built like the gods great
that's that was the thinking of the time
yeah that's one yeah in other words it
was Mean Girls it what that's exactly
what it was it was like mean girls like
16th 17th century - yeah well when I lay
back to the [ __ ] BC pew it yeah
it's going all the way back and really
Greeks but that doesn't mean that let me
tell you so let me straighten these
[ __ ] out that doesn't mean that
beauty is not something to aspire to
and that health is not something to a
spoil yeah it is it's like obviously
everyone wants to look their best yes to
feel their best I'm not saying that I'm
not saying everyone should be a big fan
no no being a [ __ ] that works
and don't bathe and stuff right exactly
obviously she you should for yourself
try to be the best version of yourself
right that but don't feel like you don't
know there's other people because
they're not as good-looking as you
yeah because like I said there's only so
much you can do within your I mean you
know and here's another thing some of
the most brilliant minds in the world
we're ugly right that's what I mean and
with that [ __ ] on people like because of
what they look like because that person
like look at Stephen Hawking for crisis
right exactly ugly man but he's like you
know a city that will [ __ ]
by a horrible disease like early and
Einstein was not and he's like the
smartest dude on earth and Einstein was
not a cute [ __ ] either but he
can't with a bunch of that's great
things and he tell us everybody
everybody has everybody everybody can
contribute right and so it's like that's
why you can't be that way right can't be
that way right and had you left this up
to the ancient Romans some of these
other [ __ ] ugly [ __ ]
would have been cut out of the picture
although Archimedes they never said how
Archimedes looked per se but the genius
of Archimedes was accepted in the
greco-roman period so he must have been
good-looking maybe maybe not he was
Socrates evidently said he had eyes like
a crab they gave him kind of an
exception so what you're getting to is
that in the ancient era you may have
been able to talk your way out of that
[ __ ] if you were smart if you were smart
enough but if you were like smart but
not quite as smart as Archimedes then
you were [ __ ] right yeah Archimedes
are you had to be like I said you you
had to be like super smart and super
good-looking and if you weren't then
right you were kind of hosed
so the Age of Enlightenment I think was
an advancement for well that's what I
mean and that's why this is I mean
that's something that I kind of like
look up to a lot like that kind of
because that was kind of the first time
in history that people are like hey you
know there's more to people than what
was you see on sale right maybe you
shouldn't just be looking at that
because it's like people have other
things to contribute everyone has
something to contribute right you know
what I mean so it's like you know I
think that's why it's a good thing so
you know getting back to like the
Halloween history [ __ ] it's like
basically we have the celts and also
kind of like a couple of the popes that
Christianized or I felt like [ __ ] to
like thank for all of our Halloween
traditions oh there's like some American
[ __ ] like spawn on it well but it all
kind of came from that early America
picked up a lot of these
old European holidays and we made that
we commercialized them including
included Christmas really Christmas
wasn't was kind of like a dead thing
well and even when I got a well in the
Protestant when the Protestants were
kind of like in charge of [ __ ] they kind
of like banned Christmas in hilarious
because they thought it was like a pagan
all this stuff about [ __ ] is all this
stuff about Santa Claus and the red suit
you know that's coca-cola yeah that was
the coca-cola company they'd written its
recent but it harkens back to like old
like Scandinavian like Cola was talking
about that but it was it was it was kind
of an invented holiday by American
corporations when you yeah but I'm out
saying this bad so we were like oh man
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] I love Christmas
right yeah a coca-cola had a good idea
they're like me no the resisting course
I'm an atheist you but it's like I love
Christmas I love Christmas [ __ ] Japan
loves Christmas then they're not
Christians don't love Chris it's just a
good it's just good celebration cold
weather is like Dakota we call the quiet
feast present yeah how can you not love
that it was awesome the coca-cola
corporation was [ __ ] RIT was really a
huge part of Christmas
well they had their bringer on the altar
bring back bring it back Santa Claus and
stuff and like I said I don't like I
said I'm you know I'm as anti corporate
as the next person but you have to like
think too that sometimes corporations
are kind of plugging into what was
cultural zeitgeist yeah at the time so
it wasn't always yes maybe because they
have like a large cultural reach that's
like maybe that's why but I don't think
that we should like [ __ ] on it just
because that's where like the past of it
was they wanted to bring back a family
thing and an Anglo American thing and it
was with making money but it was also a
way of bringing back families it was a
family day yeah which is you know wrong
there's nothing wrong with that and like
I said the same thing happen with
Halloween it's like if some people are
like pissed off Oh cause it had pagan or
origins or sub Euler pays off his pissed
off said Christian origins it doesn't
matter it's like look you are just you
and you were living at this present time
it's like you can you are free to take
or leave whatever tradition you would
like from this particular celebration
it's like if you don't like the
corporate aspects of Halloween or you
don't like the corporate aspects of
Christmas you don't have to do that you
can just like do what you want with it
yeah when you go back in time to the
Roman era when Christianity started to
[ __ ] become a prominent force in Rome
it was corporate in a way it was
corporate that's what I mean everything
is it everything's like it's like it
sucks but like everything is kind of
top-down because they're the ones with
the power so yeah there was money behind
everything is kind of like influenced by
them but that doesn't mean that you
can't enjoy things on their own merits
like if you enjoy Christmas or you enjoy
Halloween or you enjoy certain
traditions of it then just enjoy that
you don't need like an excuse for it and
ancient Roman Christianity during the
you know the first couple hundred years
of it and once the Empire picked it up
it wasn't a bad thing it was a way of
reunifying the Empire and to give a new
culture to the Roman people you know who
were because who were basically kind of
had a diverse background the time of the
Roman gods had passed they had to have
something to replace it with yeah and it
makes sense when you go back into those
days listen to run dr. Robert in price
he'll tell you all about that period and
everything we know about it it wasn't a
bad thing it still isn't really a bad
thing you just have to just it behooves
you to kind understand what it is what I
said even to go out and hate it why
would you go out and hate it even if you
don't like the origin of it right if you
like some aspects of it then there's no
reason that you just can't take those
aspects of it and just make your own
[ __ ] out of it no one's stopping you
from doing that and over this over the
millennia people have taken up
Christianity
and done what they wanted with it that
didn't mean that doesn't mean that's
what Christianity was right every every
there's been a lot of organizations over
the time and different places that have
had their own interpretations and
they've rift on it for their own gain
but that's just how that's just how life
is
that's what I mean that's how it goes
and like I'm not super worried about I
mean yeah you got to worry about some
[ __ ] that happened a long time ago
because it's so relevant to an extent
but it's like in some ways particularly
in the way that you live your life in
the way that you celebrate you know your
occasions and things like that it's like
I'm not really that worried about it's
like look I'm an atheist I'm the biggest
like atheist that ever a theist did but
I love Christmas I like I love although
I love trees I love the presents I love
like the whole like Gestalt around
Christmas it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
about Jesus I don't give a [ __ ] about
any of that I don't give a [ __ ] about
like the religious trappings of it but I
just like the whole aesthetic of it I
like the whole idea of it it's like oh
good will toward metal it's like that's
awesome I like that that's what it
always was that's what I mean and it's
like you know if you want to see that as
like me going back to the pagan roots of
it that's cool too but it's because it
kind of is that's what it was
that's what I mean so it's like I like
that aspect of it and it's like if
somebody wants to [ __ ] on me for
celebrating it just because I don't
believe in all that jesusí stuff then
that's all we're all really that sucks
because all religions were products and
it was always something behind it or a
force or a group that was behind it they
had their own you know they kind of had
their own motives yeah but that doesn't
mean the product that they were selling
was bad distinct yeah there's a
distinctive there's a lot of good things
in the history in in Western culture
they're enjoyable the message behind
them was good yeah some people some
people like abused Christianity but
Edison oceania T itself was bad it's
just everything depended on the specific
situation yeah
like I said Linville and particularly
nowadays I feel like you can kind of
pick and choose the best things about
[ __ ] right to kind of tailor things to
way you like and they were doing that
back then yeah that's not new labor no
one that [ __ ] vector especially nowadays
it's like no one's gonna [ __ ] on you for
celebrating Christmas however you want
to celebrate it it's just like Islam you
have different interpretations of that
there's so many will it take that [ __ ]
totally seriously you know a lot of my
family came up in Iran you know [ __ ]
Dearing yeah love you don't know my
family history my grand dad ended up
working for the Shah of Iran and his
fahan you know for Grumman aerospace you
know this is back in the 70s when they
were we were making at fourteen Tomcats
for the [ __ ] Shah and all my aunts
grew up in Iran and Islam is very
similar to that you can be a real
hardcore with Islam and turned it into
something that you know literal and try
to enforce like an old-fashioned laws
and then you end up with Isis or you
could take Islam and do what we do it it
just kind of [ __ ] interpreted this is
gonna like take what you like with it
it's like all the [ __ ] you don't like
just the yeah we're not gonna attack or
they can go all spiritual and become
like the Sufi you know because we know
us you know we know certain people that
have Islamic backgrounds that are out in
the club with us drinking alcohol is
that yeah that's what I mean is that big
deal like they're still Muslims but
they're still Muslim their crib yeah
they're mostly way that a lot of
Christians are out there do better Chris
sure right yeah it's like you know
that's what I mean in there and I don't
want cut and drop and like I said I
don't see any problem with that
whatsoever has to do with here you can
take what you want from it I mean when I
was in Egypt I was you know discussing
religion with Bedouins and down the
Sinai Peninsula and we're talking about
Christianity and Islam and they're
listening to me and they're like well if
if you're not a Christian fundamentalist
why don't you become a Muslim which is a
Muslim way of looking at things
yeah and I'm like you don't do that
I'm like my Christianity is a cultural
tradition and as soon as I said
tradition and I said your father
I'm telling this to an old Muslim guy I
said your father was Muslim right yeah
this is your grandfather was Muslim
right I said you wouldn't go to
Christianity would you like no because
it's not in your family tradition and
right as soon as they started seeing it
that way they're like yeah yeah right is
there a go it has to do with tradition
more than anything else see whether you
follow it or not yeah yeah and like I
said those dudes were not [ __ ] devout
Muslims [ __ ] right doing the [ __ ] like
I said there we know a lot of people
that are culturally Muslim that do [ __ ]
that quote-unquote Muslims don't deal
with like I said they're the kind same
kind of [ __ ] that like most people that
would say their aggressions but then
they do yeah but don't for one second
think the fundamentalism is not
dangerous
fundamentally any kind is dangerous but
yeah but like I said fundamentalism of
anything of any kind is damn is bad yes
like whatever religion it is whatever
anything you can look at the statistics
and you could interpret it for yourself
[ __ ] Islam as a young religion and
the [ __ ] act up cuz that's just
the way young religions are religions
like I said and you see like the kind of
you know it's it's not as prevalent in
this culture because it's been around
around so long but you do see your
fundamentalist Christians doing the
similar kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm I'm
Christian friendly and we're out waiting
to go into a club and I'll have a
Christian fundamentally Alan Ennis about
how evil we are these [ __ ]
don't know us yeah it's the same kind of
mindset what just depends on what kind
of brother you grow up and it's like
what you're attracted to right but I do
feel like like I said I feel like it's
good nowadays because I do feel like
people are more accepting of you know I
would like to you know take this that
and the other thing from this religious
tradition or you know a traditionally
religious tradition and incorporate that
into my life even though I'm not of that
religion people and that's fine I don't
think people are bothered by that human
these have a genetic inclination towards
religion if they don't have a religion
they'll make one well not even so much
religious tradition was that a tradition
that's what religion is yeah is it's a
bunch of traditions memes based upon
morals and stories and and that's what
religion is you know I mean everyone
kind of makes up a moral system they
make up tales they make you know and I
mean memes that have certain moral
implications and all religions are
basically like that in the case of Islam
you know it's not just the Quran it's
the hadith and the Sunnah and when you
talk about the hadith there's also a
legal system that goes along with it
which is something that you know a lot
of people that are Christians don't
don't [ __ ] well we don't really have
that anymore we don't have that anymore
well imagine you had something like the
New Testament along with the Old
Testament and then a law book mmm that
was yeah pulled out of the Old Testament
it would be a different you know maybe
it would change the whole it would be a
whole different dynamic we in the West
you kind of have our version of the
hadith would be church law yeah which
would be like say the laws of the
Catholic Church about you know I mean
st. rosaries and how many you know if I
can how many Hail Marys or whatever it
is it to say and what the punishments
are certain things are so we kind of
have it but it's just those our
denominational rules and so it's kind of
lost a lot of its allure in this culture
I guess depending on who you're talking
right I mean like I said it's it's hard
to extrapolate across Americans as a
rule because you know there's so much
yeah we reverse it we're 50 different
states and our states of the size of
European countries are bigger so it's
kind of Holland even within the state
and there was like sneezes [ __ ]
different there's huge like diversity
between live depending on like what
neighborhood you live in and show like
no it's like it's always like hard to
like like I said extra
played against you know across large
populations because people are so right
different in there I mean like in the
place of Mississippi where my dad came
from his Jones County Jones County has a
history itself that [ __ ] they made
movies about yeah they did yeah which
what was the name of that movie they had
old what's-his-name from I thought it
was Johnson to this day John that
flexers called the Free State of Jones
yeah you know they're talking about new
tonight who was the leader of Free State
John was Denison because you see where
my dad came from the county of Jones
waged war against the Union and the
Confederacy well it changed you know I
mean the [ __ ] the civil war from the
Confederate point of view was a rich
man's war defending defending
plantations which was kind of against
the average farmer because though the
plantations were like oh yeah that was
the incorporation and you know I mean
they were they they weren't they were
kind of against your sharecroppers and
new tonight who is the leader had a
black wife so it was there were people
that were waiting with black
sharecroppers so it was not a [ __ ] our
history was a lot more complicated than
Northern or em we call these Yankee
[ __ ] they didn't really
understand our history well like I said
everything everything was calm
everything is far more calm
yeah always when you look more yeah you
see the Free State Jones do you
understand and it was a while that's
[ __ ] Jones's a wild place yeah and in
Heidelberg or my dad lives he's the last
basically the last living white man now
Heidelberg is now a black town and you
know they love my dad I told you but you
know what he was up there in the
hospital dying dad's adorable you know
the neighbors were visiting him you know
I'm bringing turkey necks
like that you thought they put them in
his chest thaw your turkey I don't
remember what episode we talked about
that on but yeah no that was such a good
that like I've met your dad like he came
here to visit us like everyone holiday
yeah and I could just imagine what
because you do his voice really well
yeah so I cannot ajami in Oblivion yeah
I could imagine like how that went down
cuz he went away for like two weeks like
I said a long time ago like when I did
the show myself he would re for two
weeks losing his dad getting like a
heart bypass country black Mississippi
like in Halliburton his old Germantown
but all the Germans are gone now country
black Mississippi is now experienced in
the 1950s they all got cars they go to
high school they [ __ ] hang out at the
Dairy Queen you know having a good time
it's a they're they're they're they're
experiencing the 1950s American yeah
it's all black people this time around
yeah yeah yeah wow that's yeah because
you know all the old-style housing
projects became obsolete yeah and all
the white people died off in those
little towns and the houses didn't cost
much so they so the black people moved
into them and they lived a normal
suburban country lifestyle that the
white middle-class came from it's very
much 1950s you know
okay we're driving around in cars with
[ __ ] convertibles and making out
[ __ ] going to the drive-in and
they're happy all day back in the day
yeah it's not it's not like a hood type
situation that you would have in an
urban environment this is a country
environment and that's where a lot of
the US Army's coming from yeah yeah cuz
the guy that take care of my dad across
the street is a US Army guys a sergeant
yeah him and his wife that's right you
told me that yeah
you know they're there my age yeah and
their children you know and my dad takes
their children out hunting and fishing
[ __ ] love me he's like a granddad the
white granddad white grain white grad
Dwight granddad feels like it should be
a maybe yeah I haven't really met them
they were from another era so when I go
back to see him I'll have them yeah I
met him in a hospital but I didn't mean
to meditate in Heidelberg right okay
right yeah it's like no I'm too young to
go back to Heidelberg we got this
beautiful place here I don't know I need
to go back to Heidelberg yeah it's a
little bitty house you know I mean well
compared to this yeah I mean it's like I
mean it's like we live in like the hub
of like cultural vanguard or anything
like that it's like we live in Orlando
Orlando is pretty cool it's like it's at
least a decently sized city you know
they have nightclubs they have like cool
[ __ ] here Disney so it's the new
Hollywood in a certain way sort of a lot
of you we know where it's not like
Manhattan or nothing though yeah but
it's like you know there's cool [ __ ]
here the other Hollywood yeah and a lot
of people we know are kind of
entertainers yeah there's cool [ __ ] here
yeah so I don't know if I would ever I I
can't go back there like that's what I
mean I don't know if I'd ever get and
are not saying like that what I'm like
[ __ ] 90 years old that it's like yeah
I won't mind like living in my final
year yeah it's like I'm not saying that
cuz that's a long time away but at this
stage of my life yeah I'm almost 50 and
stuff like that but it's like I don't
really want to be like somewhere where
there's like no nightclubs or anything
that would like really like I've nicked
predict 30 years from now or 20 years
from now there's gonna be a new
generation of African Americans coming
from places like Heidelberg Mississippi
which were the backwoods were they
experienced a 1950s style culture
they're gonna be the ones that are gonna
[ __ ] conduct they're gonna do a
really good job in places like Hollywood
that's where the future [ __ ] yes even
Spielberg's and [ __ ]
to come from maybe so they give me some
of those guys cuz I could see that and
coming up the same way that's our answer
yeah right this Stevens feel very like I
think that kind of like small town and
all that that's the way they're come so
we might see like a new Renaissance and
riot if yeah yeah it's gonna be like a
trip because they're black which that we
don't associate our generation doesn't
associate that yeah which is weird like
I don't know it's weird that we don't
but it's weird that we don't but we
don't yeah not really
but that they're coming that's gonna be
kind of the new generation I mean there
are some of them now from the suburban
areas
yeah and I'm talking about the [ __ ]
country areas that are in the 1950's
living the American dream
they're very optimistic and of
interesting yeah I kind of want to go
there and see well yeah there's no I
don't know if I need to go there cuz I
think I can imagine it cuz I grew up in
a pretty like they're not a spoiled
people you know I'm talking about
they're there they're very much kind of
like a salt of the earth middle-class
people the same kind of people that the
spielberg era and other you know in
1950's type people came from there like
so you know it's gonna be interesting to
see how that goes
I don't know how maybe the internet
might that's what I mean I do feel like
that's not like weddings democratizer
yeah it's not the quite same situation
as before in the same way like in the
same way but it to a much larger larger
extent that as like television was right
in the early 1950s right you have more
knowledge yeah it's like a different
situation and like we were talking about
this the other day it's like I feel like
in some ways like some people trying to
extrapolate like oh x y&z happened in
the in history so it's gonna happen
again because history does tend to be
like cyclical to it next time yeah but
technology's a factor that's what I mean
I feel like there's too many like
contingencies particularly around
technology particularly nowadays and
it's like so I don't know if you can
like predict how things are going to get
formation
information can be a corrupting factor
it kind of destroys local cultures you
end up with a dam national Lord but you
might get a better thing on the other
end it's like it's kind of like you know
it's like a give and take just have to
see it's like everything else it has a
bad side and a good side you know what I
mean so okay so we were talking about
Halloween yeah so I was talking a little
bit about the history of Halloween I
wanted to talk a little bit too before I
want to get in this more horror movie
reviews - we're gonna do like stories in
the second half of the show but I want
to talk a little bit about Halloween
urban legends specifically the urban
legend that some [ __ ] out there
poisoning candy growing now this has
been a persistent rumor since what at
least the 1970s right yeah I mean I
remember hearing in the 1980s but I was
like growing up the 1980s and it's
interesting to note because this urban
legend it's an urban legend this has
literally never happened except one time
and the one time that had happened it
was a dad poisoning his own kids candy
and like putting the [ __ ] in the kids
candy back I'm not that kid who tried it
he did damn but they caught him well
what he was trying to do like what he
did and this happened in 1974 this
wasn't even like all that I remember
this story yeah yeah so his name was
Ronald O'Bryan right and he put cyanide
in Pixy Stix
yeah and then when his kids came back
from trick-or-treating so it wasn't like
a stranger giving them candy that was
poisoned or had razor blades in or
nothing like that they came back from
trick-or-treating he had put cyanide in
their [ __ ] Pixy Stix and then he like
you know surreptitiously like put it in
their candy bags now two of the kids
didn't eat it because apparently they
didn't like Pixy Stix but the one son
did eat it and he died now they caught
the guy
like I said they figured out it was the
dad like pretty quickly he got
put in prison and he got like put to
death and like 1984 I think he got like
putting the electric chair what was his
motive insurance money okay he was
trying to kill all three of his kids
apparently but he was trying to blame it
on because by 1974 that urban legend had
spread so it was so widespread that like
Oh poison candy that he was using that
yeah to get away with it yeah it wasn't
thinking right because if somebody
actually were to do that it wouldn't hit
just his kids it would hit a bunch of
kids that's what I mean you guys would
be like yeah it's a good thing but he
didn't do that because you want to like
killed a bunch of strangers [ __ ] like
that the cops would have been like no
but this it bothers me because this is
one of those things that's like and we
talked about this like a long time ago
in our satanic panic show this is kind
of one thing where you take something
that sounds I mean on its surface it
sounds pretty plausible right like yeah
there might be out there in the millions
of people in the United States there's
probably some wacko that would think it
was funny to like put a razor blade in
an apple or like yeah put poison and
candy or something like that now the
fact that that hasn't really I mean even
though we've had like 30 40 years of
like urban legends about that [ __ ] the
fact that we haven't really had that
happen to any great extent yeah maybe
that's encouraging about the human race
I'm not really sure but it's like really
there's not any cases of that happening
the only really like compelling case of
that happening it was like a dad trying
to poison his own [ __ ] kids and using
that urban legend as a backdrop yeah
that that herb that that whole ammo only
works in the era of television because
that's what was propagating that yeah
that legend now that television is on
its way out you know I mean being
replaced by the Internet you won't see
that again although you still do see
urban legends passing around it's just
that they pass around by different means
different things though I remember when
I was a kid they were worried about the
poison in the damn
when I was trick-or-treating yeah people
were still kind of worried
yeah they tell you Oh bring your candy
the hospital well x-ray it I think they
still do that we still ate that [ __ ] I
did cuz I don't share it's candy around
our local area you know two or two or
three blocks so it's not like we were
going anywhere you know we weren't going
for yeah you would that like you knew
most yeah you are you at least like saw
them every day
that's totally those people wouldn't
wouldn't [ __ ] poison the local
neighborhood kids they couldn't get away
with it one you couldn't get away with
it it's like two if you were serious
yeah yeah if you were a serial killer I
feel like you would be using different
methods yeah because what would happen
was is that the kids that got poisoned
they would ask those parents where did
you trick or treat ray and then they
would just question they would home and
they'd be able to home in on a certain
block and they would turn that block
upside down they would say to me hey who
on ice block had them damn shots or who
had the who was given away the Zots
who was given away who was it with all
caps who's David already give away some
candy that kids would actually right
let's put a bunch of razor blades in
bit-o-honey yeah well I did that like a
lot of people yeah it was legends it's
harder to poison kids and you think and
get away with well and another thing too
is that one if you're gonna kill a bunch
of people that seems like a lot of
trouble yeah like why would you buy it
like here's the thing you would have to
like buy a whole [ __ ] ton of candy and
you in the hands of different kinds and
you would have to like either inject it
with whatever poison like after you
obtained whatever poison or obtaining
you'd either have to inject or you would
have to sit there and like meticulously
like put a razor blade and like every
single Apple and then you would assume
that like the kid would actually eat the
Apple that other reasonable isn't which
most kids won't um so I would have to
you would have you and if you did it all
from the same house because that's I
mean you're just like masking port so to
me it seems like you know yes I write
about sure crime it's like I know crazy
[ __ ] happens all the time people do
stupid [ __ ] that doesn't make any sense
but something
to this extent yeah all those it would
take is one kid to remember where where
he got that candy and a lot of kids
would yeah especially if it was [ __ ]
again yeah yeah those I got them from
that old man right there on this they
get you I mean and the thing about it
too is that this urban legend goes back
even like before candy was a big thing
it's like the urban legend used to be
apples no the urban legend used to be
that there was some like crazy old
person that would like take pennies cuz
marinas give you pennies and they would
heat them up on a skillet yeah and then
they would give them to the kids who
have burned them so it wouldn't kill
them or anything but it's like that's
where but he can pick them up fine
I can't or here's like that's what kind
of how do you get away with that exact
you burn me okay call the cops so the
fact that that that the urban legend
started with that yeah because the
second you think about it it's like how
would that even have worked the one I
remember from a little kid is a razor
blade in an apple yeah everybody no one
ever gave me an apple I never got an
apple em yeah that's all I had like
maybe a couple times I got pennies from
people but they were usually like in a
little um you know there's little things
that the roll yeah the little rolls the
little rolls I used to get pennies in
those like every now and then and like
you'd be like lame yeah cuz it was like
ten cents with that you couldn't buy
anything and even in the eighties you
can get anything with that so you know
you'd remember like the old person that
gave you that um I never tried to empty
out the damn change they are they're
like I'm not buying any candy [ __ ]
kids um I remember getting maybe one or
two popcorn balls the people I made yeah
but I never ate them because my parents
were like well you know you don't know
where that came well yeah you probably
shouldn't eat anything as homemade right
it's like it's probably fine but you
know did they wash their hands that's
what I mean just to be on the safe side
it's like I don't even think it was
poison it's just like it might have like
cat poop on a nurse I started [ __ ] in
the 70s yeah and I don't I don't
remember getting
anything home made even by the seventies
everybody knew that's what I mean I got
maybe one or two popcorn balls my whole
entire childhood
yeah and that was weird even then people
be like what the [ __ ] is this of where
are the snows in California or in
Mississippi when I was a kid it was
always store-bought candy yes so you
could identify what it was that's what I
mean like the couple times I got a
popcorn ball or panties or something
like that everyone would talk about that
house like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
that person it was always like an old
person yeah like most normal people they
just gave you like either chocolate
candy or like just the cheap cheap ass
like sweet tart yeah back in the 70s an
old person might do it because they
thought that was better than the
store-bought
that's what I'm saying and and and I
feel like that's where they probably was
that's what could you trust them you
didn't know if their kitchens clean see
right that's what I mean they made have
been a hoarder yeah they might have had
it might have been like a hoarder show
where they had like pooping the rats
were crawling all they were probably
fine they were probably fine but you
just didn't well and like I said the
couple of times I got popcorn balls my
parents said that too they were just
kinda like it's probably fine but don't
eat that just don't eat that it's like
if you want a popcorn ball I'll make you
so it's kind of like that most people
did give you yeah normal candy either
like little bitty candy bars or
lollipops or tootsie rolls or something
like that remember getting lots of sweet
tarts and a little bit sweet tarts a
little bitty bag and the bottle caps
there were like three of em and a lot of
little shots
remember the Zots I remember that and
then like lots of those little [ __ ]
little rolls there are like little sweet
tarts but they were like little Necco
wafers but oh I don't strong one of
those things called yeah what the [ __ ]
were those they were they were little
bitty things yeah they were at all I
don't remember like there were just like
a tube of them yeah yeah I got a lot of
those sweeties yeah lots of those those
are pretty good I actually like this
better than the sweet tarts oh I'm not a
I'm not a fan of like either but yeah if
I had to pick however the bottle caps
like I said they would give
like the packs and it's like there was
three of them like in a paper you know
envelope or whatever and it's like I was
me and my brother dear ones yeah those
are the only good ones yeah Ruby I like
them all like I ate them all
I like the Ruby no the repair one said
that like I once I thought like I was so
I would pick through and like open all
the things and then like me and my
brother would dump them all into one
bowl oh you know what else the little
boxes of jujubes that's right and little
boxes of jujubes or a little little tiny
they were like like a juicy fruit but
they were harder yeah they can [ __ ]
pull your teeth out yeah jujubes also
the total also the dum-dums dum-dums a
little box we got a lot of those little
boxes of Boston baked beans yep yep does
that's all old school candy I think well
in the 70s and early 80s most I mean
that was kind of like the exempted candy
that you a people was just like that
kind of [ __ ] yeah it's like if you went
cuz every now and then if I had a ride
yeah I would go cuz I can I grew up kind
of poor so we would kind of like sneak
over to the richer neighborhood a little
costume is to pretend that we were from
that neighborhood so we would get the
good [ __ ] they do that to us to here
well I don't blame him I used to do that
too when I was a kid it's like look it's
like money you know the neighborhood
where they lived they probably got
shitty candy yeah they want fruit they
want good fries we were good at the rich
people's neighborhood they'd give like
whole Snickers bar some holy [ __ ] notice
we notice you used to get a lot of with
those damn butterscotch oh I loved it
and they were all red butterscotch
candies get lots of those and like what
are those [ __ ] things that are like
they're like rectangular and they're
like oh they're kind of peanut buttery
but they have like that hard white [ __ ]
on the outside and laughs as ever
no it's not than that I know what that
is but it's like they're about that big
like if you can see and then they're
wrapped up in the thing and they have
like brown stripes yeah yeah you're told
my Mary Jane no it's not a Mary Jane I
know what that is they don't remember
what the name of it was they were good
but they were like crunchy and they were
like kind of peanut buttery but not
exactly and then they had like the white
hard
think I'm out a long time that's old
school we used to get a lot of those you
get a lot of - I like those though now -
rolls in truck and I don't like to be
used to get lots of those now look they
were long and skinny back in those days
now I have to say though the flavored
tootsie rolls the vanilla ones yeah
they're good those kick ass yeah but
like the original yeah yeah the are they
even chocolate no are this fudge
[ __ ] it's not supposed to be fudge
it's supposed to be I feel like maybe
it's not though
what I don't know what it is but don't
worry about it I like the flavored one I
don't read once in the white well
flavored ones are good yeah okay didn't
have those when I was a kid no I they
didn't either I thought like they came
about later it wasn't there was another
company that made ones like that yeah
that had like a shiny like a foil
wrapper yeah there were like tootsie
rolls but they were flavored like the
you know the modern yeah flavored
sincero they had vanilla and strawberry
and orange and all that kind of [ __ ] and
they tasted about the same but I feel
like tootsie rolls got in on that action
because everyone was like tootsie rolls
are super gross because they are but the
rules are not gross yes they are
okay um now I'm gonna rest my case after
I say this but you know how they make
those [ __ ] cakes that look like a
kitty litter box a cake that looks like
a litter box yeah are you talking about
there's a cake that you make that looks
like a litter box I am no what you
talking about there ELR will called me
talking about it's a cake and like look
you make a cake and then on the top of
it you make like a topping that looks
like litter like same colour is it
well it looks like a litter box it's a
chocolate cake underneath well you can
make any kind of cake you want it is but
it's like it's like a chocolate cake
underneath on the top you make like a
topping that looks like litter or like
sand or whatever and then for the poop
you use tootsie rolls I ain't good about
them that are a little bit melted no
I've never seen it it's true
I'm telling you that's that's I have
been to so many Halloween parties that
had that that's some [ __ ] that came from
your fucked-up neighborhood we would
never do anything like that were you
talking about
look it's to look on Instagram kitty
litter cake no it's a thing it's a thing
he doesn't believe me it's a no remember
those ice cream bars that were white
they had all the little white chips of
the little in a little strawberry they
were like white and strawberry and on
the outside of it they have like white
little chips with little red ones in
there too and then you know I remember
that one and ice cream bar yeah it was
like it was this chalk it was vanilla
and strawberry back in the seventies I
can't believe you don't I'm gonna kill
you later kid what else is new what else
is new we done have we got to get this
show going quite the show okay I'm just
telling you I was gonna do like a couple
more like a horror movie recommend okay
yeah good do you want to do that okay
you're gonna die you're gonna die are
you gonna be alright it's almost
midnight yeah maybe we do tomorrow
quit do
huh nope okay well cook what you know
when I got to see your little belly what
the Beijing went over there and sat on
her little throne she is not impressed
with baby cookies rolling abilities
cookies like woman and get get on this
on that yeah
are you eating her catnip probably
hey okay we're going round and round
[Music]
going round oh oh
confrontation confrontation what's up
[Laughter]
okay
Beijing is asserting her dominance